Das war's für heute.
irgendwie
So Leute, da bin ich eigentlich.
Kann ich euch gleich sagen, es war heute eigentlich gar kein Stream geplant.
Ich wollte heute eigentlich MMO-Kreisel-Crime machen, aber sind nicht alle Leute da und
mit random group oder mit zu viel random Leuten spielen.
Ihr kennt mich, ich drehe da immer am Rad, das geht nicht, das kann ich mir nicht geben.
Deswegen heute kein MMO-Kreisel-Crime und dann für eine Runde streamen.
Dementsprechend habe ich nichts vorbereitet, wir machen heute auch keine Set-Servers oder
irgendwas, das ist viel zu spät und viel zu kaputt dafür.
Hast du schon Overwatch 2 gespielt?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht vor.
Ich habe dir immer einen Zapfgesapf gegiftet, weil du irgendwie immer da bist.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert, ob du wirklich den ganzen Tag auf Twitch unterwegs
bist oder ob du einen Bot hast, keine Ahnung.
Ah, na, mein Fall wäre es nicht.
Was ist das?
Du du du du du du du du du du du.
Säck.
So, alles klar.
So, ne, wie gesagt, ich habe weder Overwatch 2 gespielt, noch generell Overwatch in der
letzten Zeit.
Overwatch 2 und Overwatch 1 ist ja Multiplayer, das gleiche Game, da fehlen ein paar Sachen,
aber ist eigentlich schon der Singleplayer, ist schon der Overwatch 2 Singleplayer raus,
dass das was damals groß angekündigt wurde?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Sleckware hat noch eine Frage zu Vmware.
Er nutzt Virtual Box.
Ja, kann man auch machen.
Was siehst du für Vorteile gegenüber Virtual Box?
Ich kenne Vmware nur die kostenpflichtigen Diensthalle, aber für meine Zwecke nicht sinnvoll,
das Kostmodell gefällt mir nicht.
Ja, dir muss das Kostmodell auch nicht gefallen, weil du kannst ja einfach vor 2,50 Euro bei
einem Key Seller was kaufen.
Das kann man sich schon leisten.
Also ich benutze Vmware, weil es mehr Funktionen hat.
Weil die, also ich beziehe das jetzt auf die Vmware Workstation Version unter Windows.
Bin mir nicht sicher, ob das überall so ist, aber ich würde es jetzt mal vermuten.
Zum Beispiel du Snapshots gescheit machen kannst, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob
Virtual Box überhaupt Snapshot-Support hat.
Kann Virtual Box Snapshots machen?
Ja, das ist eigentlich der Hauptpunkt, dass ich ordentlich Snapshotverwaltung habe.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es da vielleicht früher Probleme gab, weil ich habe das überhaupt
nicht im Kopf, dass Virtual Box das kann.
Weil ich die Bedienung angenehmer finde und weil ich den Eindruck habe, das habe ich aber
noch nie so wirklich direkt verglichen, weil ich den Eindruck habe, dass die 2, 2, 3D,
2 und 3D Acceleration besser funktioniert.
Aber ansonsten, und außerdem ist Virtual Box Oracle, ja das stimmt, Oracle ist ja
eh schon mal per Definition abfuck.
Aber wenn das alles kann, was du machen willst, dann können wir doch mal gucken, ob es da
nicht irgendwie einen Vergleich dazu gibt.
Wenn das alles kann, was du haben willst, dann macht es ja eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Nur weil ich das verwende, irgendwie mal anders, ok, was sagt denn Reddit dazu?
Ja, außer viel, genau, den Eindruck hatte ich auch, wie gesagt, dass 2D, 3D Acceleration
besser funktioniert mit Forever.
Der Typ schreibt irgendwie einen stumpfen Sinn, Alter, der Typ meint doch eindeutig
Forever Workstation.
Alter, die Reddit-Antworten sind ja mal wieder richtig pepega, brain-dead.
Die haben glaube ich nicht verstanden, was der Typ überhaupt gefragt hat.
Loser, danke schon für den Sub, Pog, woher das kommt, das ist ein Emote, das ist dieses
Emote hier, guck, nur ohne die Animation.
Nice, gucken wir nachher rein.
Ich meine, vor allem wer hat eine 30-Tage-Testversion, die du glaube ich einfach in die Vollversion
upgraden kannst und seriously, der Vorteil, dass Virtual Box kostenlos ist, ok, der ist
da, aber guckt mal, wie billig man Forever Workstation Keys mittlerweile bekommt, wenn
man jetzt nicht unbedingt gerade im offiziellen Shop den Kram kauft, sondern bei irgendeinem
Key Seller, da fällt das nicht wirklich ins Gewicht, außerdem, bei mir ist es eh egal,
ich habe tatsächlich mittlerweile sogar ein Office 365 Abo, ich hätte nie gedacht, dass
ich im Leben jemals ein Office 365, Microsoft 365 heißt es ja offiziell, man weiß immer
noch nicht so genau, warum das unbenannt wurde, hätte ich auch nie gedacht, dass ich
mir das jemals kaufe.
Ja, Spider-Schwein, ich weiß, dass das gibt, aber das werde ich dir nicht zeigen.
Wie findest du Windows 11 mittlerweile, warum bist du umgestiegen, seriously, ich finde
von Tag zu Tag finde ich Windows 11 beschissener, ich entdecke immer mehr Bugs, die mir extrem
auf den Sack gehen, zum Beispiel, die Bugs kann man oftmals nicht so richtig provozieren,
sie sind öfters da, zum Beispiel, das stört mich ja schon immer, das nervt mich ja schon
immer dieses Gruppierte von Anwendungen, aber es gibt jetzt einen neuen Bug, den ich am
Anfang gar nicht so richtig realisiert habe, manchmal erscheint dieses Auswahlfenster hier
gar nicht, also es kommt oft genug vor, gerade wenn man viele Anwendungen laufen hat, da
von manchen Anwendungen auch noch 3D Inhalte, Rändern und sowas, da gehst du drüber und
das, was hier aufploppt, erscheint dann einfach gar nicht, dann musst du auf die Taskleiste
drücken, dass die Taskleiste sich wieder fokussiert wurde und dann geht das wieder, also wie kaputt
kann das denn sein, ich verstehe eh nicht den Sinn davon, ehrlich gesagt, wir hatten
seit Windows 95 bis Windows, ich bin mir nicht sicher ob Windows 7 oder Windows XP, ehrlich
gesagt, aber die haben die Taskleiste eine ganze Zeit lang kontinuierlich weiterentwickelt,
von Windows 95, 98, ME, 2000 bis Windows XP und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, die hatte
natürlich auch so ein paar Eigenheiten, aber im Großen und Ganzen war das irgendwie so
ein Look and Feel und eine Bedienung, die war okay, ich meine Windows 95 war damals schon
irgendwie so ein großer Wurf für die damalige Zeit, aber ihr kennt mich, ich mag das ja
eh gerne minimalistisch, deswegen ja auch bei mir in der Linux VM, da ist ja eigentlich
gar nichts, aber guck mal, ich habe es ausgeschaltet, naja, da ist ja gar nichts, es ist ja alles
im Fullscreen und dann haben sie angefangen, Windows 95 ging das ganze auch noch, dann
haben sie angefangen mit Windows 8, Windows 8 gab es ja gar keine Taskleiste am Anfang
und Fensterkopierungen, sowas und dann haben die angefangen mit Windows 8.2 oder wie das
hieß, mit Windows 10, Windows 11, die haben jedes Mal das komplett umgekrempelt und ich
verstehe den Sinn davon einfach nicht. Ich habe gestern, vor ein paar Tagen, habe ich
für meinen Vater, ich habe ein bisschen Computer Support gemacht, ich habe für meinen Vater
eingestellt, der sieht nicht mehr so gut, der ist 75 glaube ich mittlerweile, und da
habe ich eingestellt größere Mauszeige und größere Schriftart, wisst ihr, dass das Startmenü
nicht skaliert richtig mit der Schriftart, ich, warte mal, vielleicht kann ich euch das
zeigen, Font, Make Text Size Bigger, also guckt es euch jetzt mal an, ja hier, keine Ahnung,
Update, Update, so und jetzt, so wir machen es bei 125, ich hoffe es geht noch, ich hoffe
es, ja, ach guck mal, hier funktioniert das anscheinend, ich habe gestern, na nee, nee,
hier passt ja auch schon nicht mehr alles drauf jetzt, seht ihr, das skaliert nämlich
nicht richtig, wahrscheinlich ist einfach meine Auflösung höher, dass es nicht so
früh auffällt, über sein Monitor, aber seht ihr hier, hier fängt es schon an nicht mehr
richtig zu skalieren, also man kann es ja mal ganz extrem machen, guckt mal, seht ihr,
dieses dumme Startmenü wird einfach nicht größer man, mit größerer Schrift, was zum
Teufel haben sich denn die pepega Leute bei Microsoft dabei gedacht man, also mit manchen
Sachen geht es jetzt, vor allem wenn es umbricht, wieder alles auf eine Zeile, es ist einfach
lächerlich man, ich meine, warum kann das Startmenü nicht einfach so gehen oder kann
man das Fullscreen stellen, kann man das Startmenü wenigstens das Fullscreen machen, wahrscheinlich
nicht oder, ja und das ist ein Punkt den ich echt beim besten Willen nicht verstehe, warum
muss man zu jeder Windows Version das umstellen irgendwie, das da, seht ihr mal, das habe
ich gar nicht gefunden, das habe ich gar nicht gefunden, ich meine, ich habe hier gesucht
nach Font Size und dann findet man das, ok, man muss auf Scale, es ist aber auch schon
wieder, warum ist das so undurchsicht, übrigens heute ist mein iPhone angekommen, ich höre
mir gerade so nebenbei an, mal einrichten alles, so und, ach komm, ob das, ob das,
nein, das mache ich jetzt nicht, dann kackt alles ab, also ich verstehe nicht, ich verstehe
nicht, warum man das wirklich neu entwickeln muss jedes Mal, warum hätte man nicht das
nehmen können, was man mit Windows 7 neu entwickelt hat oder mit, ne, Windows 7 war
so ein Hybridding, mit Windows 10 und hätte das ausbauen können, warum musste man den
ganzen Scheiß nochmal neu machen und nochmal schlechter, ich verstehe es einfach nicht,
ja, ich weiß, man kann das ganze austauschen, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob Third Party,
Taskleiste und Startmenü wirklich der weisheitsletzter Schluss sind, ich verstehe es einfach nicht,
warum macht man es absichtlich scheiße, das raffe ich bei Microsoft echt nicht, also umso
mehr ich Windows, also ich war schon kein großer Fan von Windows 10 in vielen Stellen,
es gibt ja auch einige Vorteile von Windows 11, da habe ich ja sogar mal ein Video drüber
gemacht, ich sage ja gar nichts, es gibt ja durchaus Vorteile von Windows 11, aber ich
verstehe es einfach nicht, das ging doch in der Steinzeit ging das schon, zu Windows 95
sonst wie was, das war besser, ohne Scheiß, das war besser als 2023 in großen Teilen,
was es damals als GUI Design gab, ich verstehe es einfach nicht, ich meine, das sieht heute
schicker aus, das ist keine Frage, es ist alles ein bisschen tabletisiert, so zum Beispiel
dieser Schrott hier, den keiner braucht, aber, oder Widgets, oder so ein Shit, wobei das
habe ich ja sogar schon ausgeplant, es gibt ja gar keine Widgets, benutzt irgendjemand
diese Widgets überhaupt, diesen Krempel da, Widgets, niemand benutzt das, oder, das ist
komplette Totgeburt wieder, oder Chat, niemand, keine Sau benutzt das, genau, und mich nervt
seit Jahren ja schon, dass Desktop Anwendung und generell das Desktop UI Design sich zunehmend
tabletisiert, oder mobilisiert, oder wie soll ich es nennen, also das Desktop UI Design
zunehmend sich an Touch Geräten orientiert, und das halt auch auf Geräten, wo Maus und
Tastatur einfach das beste ist zum benutzen, ja ich weiß warum das so ist, die haben keinen
Bock verschiedene Anwendungen zu programmieren, oder verschiedene UIs zu designen, weil es
gibt ja mittlerweile auch Surface Books, die man touchen kann und so, aber das ist Scheiße,
das ist eine richtige, richtige Scheißentwicklung, ich will Desktop Anwendungen haben, die sich
gut auf dem Desktop bedienen lassen, mit Maus und Tastatur, viele Funktionen haben,
und nicht künstlich eingeschränkt werden, oder künstlich komplizierter gemacht werden
auf dem Desktop, weil ja irgendwo Tablet Benutzer, ja verstehe ich nicht, tja, warum es den Unterschied
zwischen Teams und Private Teams Account Gedöns überhaupt gibt, leuchtet mir auch nicht ein,
also ich persönlich bin der Meinung, Windows XP, also wenn man jetzt mal nur Windows nimmt,
an mein Linux I3 Ding kommt, was ist jetzt los, kommt hier eh nix ran, das finde ich
ist für mich immer noch das beste Setup, was es gibt, wir haben noch diese komischen
Icons eingestellt, sehe ich gerade, Moment, das muss ich mal kurz rausschmeißen, habe
ich hier auch die, ne, hier habe ich schon die anderen Icons, starten wir nochmal kurz
neu, so, das ist mir immer noch am liebsten, aber trotzdem, ich verstehe es einfach nicht,
wie man es immer schlechter machen kann, es gibt viele Bereiche, es ist besser, die Settings
sind schon deutlich besser als in Windows 10, aber ich persönlich bin der Meinung, den
besten Kompromiss aus Optik und Chooseability hatten sie in Windows XP, Windows XP ist quasi
mehr oder weniger die Weiterentwicklung von den Sachen davor, also das was davor ging,
ging da eigentlich auch alles, nur noch mal verbessert und ich mochte das Windows XP Design,
dass das bunt war, also das so, ne blau war die glaube ich, ne grüner Taskbutton, blauer
Taskleister, da kommt ja die Wiese im Hintergrund auch her, das war das beste Design und von
der Usability, der beste Kompromiss.
Das Suchmenü, gab es jemals eine Windows Version wo die Suche, die eingebaute Suche
noch nicht für den Arsch war, also ich persönlich war Windows XP mit Abstand am besten, aber
gut, die Geschmäcker sind ja verschieden was das angeht, Windows 7 ging auch ganz gut
klar, ja, Vista war tatsächlich auch noch ganz ok, was das angeht, Windows Vista hat
ja quasi die Grundlage gelegt für das was heute in Windows ist, also vieles, vieles
davon kam mit Vista, zum Beispiel der Composite Manager im Hintergrund und ich glaube DWM
heißt das Ding unter Windows, also vieles von dem was wir heute unter Windows uns vorstellen
kam ja mit Vista, das war aber auch noch irgendwo in Ordnung, zumindest was diese Sache anging
mit dem Menü und der Leiste und allem, ne ne ne mir gehts nicht darum dass sie das Design
ändern, nicht prinzipiell, das ist schon ok, ich hatte beispielsweise keinen Schmerzen
mit dem Design von XP oder auch Vista, mir gehts darum warum sie die Funktionalität,
also warum die neueren Versionen weniger Funktion haben und schlechter sind als davor, das leucht
mir nicht ein, na also ich glaube, ich glaube funktionieren tut VirtualBox auch ganz gut,
performanstechnisch CPU mäßig dürfte kein Unterschied sein, Virtualisierung macht nahezu
nichts an der CPU Performance, also es ist in der heutigen Zeit vollkommen egal ob du
was in der VM oder auf deinem Host betreibst, es macht CPU Technisch oder rein von der CPU
Performance so gut wie kein Unterschied.
Jan Friede, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Was sagst du zu den Tabs im Explorer, ok ja das ist tatsächlich sinnvoll, wie gesagt
ich hab ja auch gesagt es gibt ja durchaus sinnvolle Features unter Windows 11, so ist
das ganze nicht, aber das was du mit Abstand am meisten anklickst ist halt schlechter,
das, das verstehe ich einfach nicht, das war aber bei Release auch noch nicht drinnen
die Tabs im Explorer oder, ja bin ich nur, nur wegen dem, nur wegen dem Scan,
ich, es ist egal, ich werd das nicht mehr umstellen jetzt, ich installiere das bestimmt
nicht, ok, ja könnte man mal ausbrennen, aber ganz ehrlich ich werd jetzt nicht mehr
umsteigen, ich werd jetzt nicht downcranen oder so, bleibt jetzt so, ich installiere das
jetzt nicht neu, ja später, später gab es zumindest wieder den Startbutton, aber immer
noch diesen komischen Taskselector, Mister Armag, Mister Armag, Dankeschön für den
Sub, wenn du die 200% Schriftgröße hast, dann ist es doch sinnvoll, das so zu machen,
dass man alles lesen kann, und übrigens Fullscreen Startmenü ist überhaupt gar nicht so das
große Problem, das Problem an Windows 8 war, dass das Null in den eigentlichen Windows
Workflow integriert war, ist der Finder und der Mac OS nicht auch Fullscreen?
Ne, aber größer, ne, ne dann mein ich gar nicht den Finder, wie heißt denn das Startmenü
in Mac OS, ich dachte das Ding heißt Finder, wie heißt denn das, Launchpad, ja das ist
doch auch mehr oder weniger Fullscreen, ne, genau, das ist überhaupt kein Problem wenn
das Fullscreen ist, es war einfach nur schrottig in Windows 8 integriert in den Rest, Spotlight
ist die Suche, der Tesla wurde heute gekauft, Pog, erzähl mal, was hat's gekauft, ne, du
hast schon erzählt, ne, du hast den gebraucht gekauft, oder was heißt gebraucht, gebraucht
hört sich immer so negativ an, aber du hast den gebraucht gekauft im Endeffekt, was ich
auch vollkommen nachvollziehen kann und ich wahrscheinlich auch so machen würde, ich
glaube der ist ja auch wenn du es so willst gebraucht, also nicht mein Tesla, mein Auto,
mein Fiat, mein Elektro Fiat, ist ja auch wenn du es so willst gebraucht, der war ja
auch schon 6 Monate woanders im Einsatz, ja wahrscheinlich ich verstehe es auch nicht
so genau, das ist auch ein Punkt der mich aktuell bei vieler Software gerade auf dem
Desktop nervt, guckt euch, ich mein das Windows Mail Programm ist schlechter, deswegen benutzte
das auch gar nicht mehr, vielleicht ist es mittlerweile auch besser geworden, aber das
Windows Mail Programm ist schlechter als Outlook Express, gut, kannst Outlook Express
heute nicht mehr verwenden, aber Outlook Express damals konnte mehr als das Windows Mail Programm
von heute, zwischenzeitlich gab es noch Outlook Express für Windows Live und so komischen
Blödsinn, na optisch war Outlook Express garantiert auch kein Hingucker ja, MS Intune
was ist das, ist das auch in Office 365 dabei, ach das ist so ein MDM Shit von Microsoft,
boah hör mal auf, wie es dem Friseur geht, dem scheint es ganz gut zu gehen, da ist jetzt
Unterwäsche Model, Fitness Studio Model und macht Dinger wo man schön sein muss für
und gut ausschauen in Videos und nebenbei weiß ich nicht, nebenbei arbeitet er glaube
ich, arbeitet er glaube ich immer noch im Tattoo Studio, zumindest war das glaube ich, wenn
ich mich richtig erinnere, das letzte was ich gehört habe, ja ja, ich kenne die Fitness
Studio Sachen leider nicht, es wurde mir hier im Chat berichtet, ich habe mich noch nicht
gefragt, es wurde mir hier im Chat berichtet, dass der Friseur wohl für irgendeine Fitness
Kette in Dresden auf in irgendwelchen Videos zu sehen ist, wo er wohl besonders männlich
auf einem Laufband joggen muss, Poggers, ich sag euch wie es ist, der Fabian hätte der
sein Real Life oder sein Real Life Beauty Kanal damals weiter gemacht, das wäre heut
der größte oder sagen wir mal einer der größten, wenn nicht der größte männliche
so Beauty Lifestyle Channel, mit Lifestyle meine ich jetzt nicht so hier wieder ins
Kopf Nico oder sowas, aber das wäre heute einer der größten so Beauty, Beauty Lifestyle
und Styling könnte man es glaube ich nennen Channels auf Deutschland, in Deutschland ich
sag es euch, der hatte damals ein der Fabian hieß das glaube ich gemacht auf YouTube, da
ist er, YouTube, das da, ne das nicht, das ist er zwar aber das ist nicht ein Video,
ok keine Ahnung wie der Channel hieß, da wo er auch Longboard Dinger vorgestellt hat
und sowas, der hat nen Video Moment Friseur Männer Haare richtig Föhnen, das hat irgendwie
1,5 Millionen Aufrufe oder sowas, oh keine Ahnung wie das Video heißt, heißt es vielleicht
das einfach nur, Moment der hat auch bestimmt auf YouTube seinen Channel verlinkt, da steht
er schon nackig rum, der hat doch bestimmt Kanäle, Fabian Reloaded, könnte es das sein,
da ist er, da ist er doch hier, das ist ein richtiges Tier mittlerweile der Friseur, guckt
es euch mal an er und das ist jetzt aber auch schon wieder 8 Jahre her, so und er hat ein
Video gemacht Männer Haare Styling hier sowas, hätte der diese Sachen weiter gemacht, guck
mal 541.000 Aufrufe, das ist fast so viel wie das Schneestells Video, hätte der solche
Videos in dieser Art so Training, Styling, Beauty Zeug hätte der weiter gemacht, das
wäre heute einer der größten männlichen so Beauty Lifestyle Styling Channels auf YouTube,
das kann ich euch garantieren, aber ich verstehs auch, ich glaube da, ich weiß ja auch was
mit Tattoos auf diesem Channel hat, keine Ahnung, aber ich kanns ja auch verstehen warum
er das nicht mehr machen wollte oder warum er keinen Bock hatte das wirklich langfristig
zu machen und der Grund war ihm gingen die Leute auf den Sack und das kann ich verstehen,
YouTube Zuschauer sind zu einem nicht unerheblichen Anteil einfach so dumm, dass es nervt und
das kann ich verstehen, dass er da keinen Bock drauf hatte, gerade wenn du dir die Comments
auch alle durchliest, mach ich ja auch, ich lese ja auch alle Comments durch immer noch,
gerade wenn du das alles durchliest und dann vielleicht sogar noch versuchst nachzuvollziehen
warum haben sie das geschrieben, ich weiß noch das ging eben immer richtig auf den Sack
wenn es dumme Kommentare gegeben hat, also dumme Kommentare nicht so dieses alter du
bist gay oder so oder irgendwie dummes Zeug was manche Deppen gepostet haben, sondern
so richtig dumme Kommentare weil sie es nicht verstanden haben was er im Video gesagt hat.
Es gibt einfach einen riesen Anteil an Leuten auf YouTube die richtig dämlich sind, hättest
du mal Schneestellzweiliger Quatsch das habe ich bis heute nicht verstanden aber der hat
ja viele Aufrufe auf einem Video mit dem Inhalt wie er es machen wollte nicht Schneestellz
wo ich rumgelaufen bin und auf einmal hat es 2 Millionen Aufrufe ja und das hat ihn wirklich
abgefuckt und deswegen hat er auch keinen Bock mehr auf YouTube gehabt weil die Leute ok
es war vielleicht auch nicht förderlich dass wir damals Call of Duty Content gemacht haben
und ich glaube Call of Duty Content hat bestimmt heute auch immer noch eventuell neben Fortnite
die höchste Low IQ Dichte auf YouTube es ist unglaublich was da für Leute rumlaufen
also im Gaming Bereich im Gaming Bereich ja es gibt durchaus Channels es gibt durchaus
Channels auf YouTube die eben nicht im Gaming Bereich wo das auch deutlich schlimmer ist
ich lege meinen Mauscursor immer über deinen Max
der Tag war anstrengend Leute pass mal auf ich erzähle euch jetzt was das wollt ihr
wahrscheinlich nicht wissen und nicht hören ich auch nicht keine Sorge ist jetzt nichts
super gesellschaftskritisches oder sowas ist eigentlich eher was lustiges aber ihr werdet
sagen ihr wollt jetzt nicht wissen danach könnt nicht wetten und zwar ich hab ja heute
bisschen PC Support für meinen Vater gemacht ja der hat irgendwie nicht hingekriegt an
sein Rechner das musst du dir mal vorstellen der benutzt Computer auch schon seit 20 Jahren
oder so der hat einen Kopfhörer an sein Rechner angeschlossen und hat sich dann gewundert
dass kein Sound rauskommt und dann habe ich mich per TeamViewer bei ihm eingeloggt und
hab einfach nur folgendes gemacht glaube ja und hab ne andere Sound Output ausgewählt
das war's mehr hab ich nicht gemacht danach ging der Kopfhörer und da hab ich gesagt
so jetzt probier mal aus ob das alles funktioniert und da hat er Chrome aufgemacht und Zeug aufgemacht
und jetzt kommt der Hammer Leute jetzt kommt der Hammer er klickt in seinem Startmenü
rum und verklickt sich und wisst ihr was aufgeht ratet mal es geht auf YEP was geht auf YEP
also auf einmal geht so ein Dickpick auf von ihm und ich denk mir so alter das wollte ich
jetzt net sehen ein Dickpick man warum hat der Typ auf seinem Rechner ein Bild von seinem
Ding ich mein der ist 75 ihr könnt ihr könnt euch vorstellen also es ist jetzt nicht so
dass man sich denkt dass Leute sich denken irgendwo im Internet oh ja das wollte ich
schon immer mal sehen keine Ahnung ey das wollte ich echt nicht sehen der hatte ihn
wirklich immer anscheinend hatte die Bilder immer bereit wie es aussieht wenn die schon
im Task irgendwie in unter den last used falls oder so stehen dass man sich im Taskmenü verklicken
kann also wirklich Leute sicherlich medizinische das ist keine medizinische Gründe hast du
was dazu gesagt ich habe gesagt ja das wollte ich jetzt nicht sehen habe ich gesagt am Telefon
das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich nicht sehen ja ich mache ja schon wieder weg oh man so
genau habe ich mir nicht angeguckt das war eher so von oben fotografiert man hat sonst
nicht viel gesehen aber vor man ist das Open Source auf GitHub App Launcher brauche ich
nicht GitHub nur wenn es Open Source ist sonst ist sowas installiere ich mir nicht sonst
ist Richard Stallman böse auf mich wenn ich keine Open keine Free and Open Source Software
verwende Flow Launcher soll übrigens ganz gut sein das habe ich jetzt schon ein paar
mal gehört auch auf Reddit Leute Only Free Liebere Open Source Software was man ja auch
daran sieht dass ich so Sachen wie Vegas verwende ich benutze übrigens noch Vegas 13 für die
Videos alles alles Free und Open Source ja das benutzt du ok ich werde es auch mal ausprobieren
dann brauche ich vielleicht dieses dumme Startmenü nicht mehr ich meine man darf nicht vergessen
es ging lange Zeit noch nicht mal ok geht immer noch nicht alles zu track und droppen auf die
Startleiste also wenn du jetzt hast wenn du jetzt das ging übrigens unter Windows XP
und sowas immer also wenn man jetzt sagt ich möchte gerne Dateiverknüpfung hier drauf
fliegen weil ich die so oft brauche ne ne ne ne ne ne ne das geht nicht du kannst auch
moment ordentlich verknüpfen geht auch nicht ich dachte das geht mittlerweile ach das geht
ok das funktioniert und Sachen runter geht runterziehen geht auch nicht ok nice tolle
Feature Sachen Dinger die Windows 95 konnte kann es nicht mehr geht es mit rechter Maustaste
mal ausprobieren kann es auch noch wenn du willst mit mittlerer Maustaste kann man nicht
tracken nope nope so schlecht oder wenn du eine Verknüpfung anlegst dann wird es wahrscheinlich
funktionieren das ist so schlecht alles man warum Sunderbird wenn du ein Office 365 Abo
hast naja ich habe Office 365 nicht für Outlook Outlook ist mir viel zu viel zu bloated Sunderbird
verwende ich ehrlich gesagt auch nur für eigentlich bräuchte ich gar nicht mehr
könnte man es genauso in den Browser angucken nur ein paar I-Map Postfächer sonst nix ich mache
damit sonst nix außer aus ein paar I-Map Postfächer angucken ab und zu ok
ja ich verstehe den Sinn auch nicht das ist komplett verschwendeter Platz hier ist ja nix
hier ist ja nix du brauchst es ja für nix
wenn man ja wenigstens noch die Namen anzeigen lassen könnte daneben aber das geht ja glaube
ich auch nicht man kann nicht mal die Namen hier daneben anzeigen lassen guckt mal man
sieht man sieht ja schon dass es Müll ist guck mal ich habe hier unten meine selbst
meine selbst gebastelte Anwendung die hat kein Icon ok aber wenn ich einen Namen daneben
stehen hätte dann wüsste ich wenigstens was was ist wenn ich es offen habe aber nee gibt
es nicht ich meine woher soll ich wissen dass dieses Konsolen Fenster zu diesem zu diesem
gestarten Programm gehört woher ja war geil weil da jetzt in der Vorschau Web Application
steht dafür kann man so ein Müll hier ein ausblenden ok ist einfach schlecht gemacht
1 2 1 2 kannst du ausschalten gibt es ein Trick was heißt ein Trick gibt es jetzt mal
gibt ein Trick du gehst in Task Manager und dann gehst du auf Startup Apps und dann sagst
du OneDrive Disable dann geht dir OneDrive nicht mehr auf den Sack
kannst du machen und ich habe vor ein paar Tagen Windows 11 installiert das ging offline
noch ich habe aber auch den Stacker rausgezogen vom Netzwerk für die Installation vielleicht
lag es daran das ging aber das war Windows 11 Professional was ich installiert habe vielleicht
geht das in anderen Versionen nicht mehr ja ich weiß es gibt immer Varianten Leute um
das zu skippen das Problem ist doch dass es Default ist du kannst auch die CMD öffnen
während dem Windows Setup und dort irgendwelche Kram eingeben
ist ist die Zeitzone in Deutschland ne weder noch CET ist unsere Zeitzone weder MEZ und
noch PT CET ist unsere Zeitzone ach ne du meinst auf Deutsch geschrieben du meinst auf
Deutsch geschrieben ne dann ist es MEZ Central European Time ist Mitteleuropäische Zeit
auf jaja ich kenne ich kenne siehste ein weiterer Grund den Kram einfach auf Englisch zu stellen
wer ist der Friseur jemand mit dem ich frühe Videos zusammen gemacht habe den ich aber
auch schon lange vor YouTube kannte wir haben uns in einem MMO kennengelernt lustigerweise
was ich heute immer noch spiele
welches MMO Dark Age of Camelot spiele ich immer noch auf einem Free Chart regelmäßig
hätte ich eigentlich heute Abend auch wieder spielen wollen aber die Leute waren nicht
da und nicht genug Leute da ja finde ich auch blöd dass er aufgehört hat auf Twitch der
konnte immer wieder streamen ich hab die Streams immer gerne geguckt leider gibt es auch keine
Aufzeichnung mehr von den alten Streams
Blender meinst du Video Zeug nee hab ich auch nicht vor
Schnitt Software ist so ein Ding wenn man sich da an eine Sache gewöhnt hat will man
eigentlich nichts anderes benutzen
ja wie gesagt ich bin ich hab meine Zweifel ob Third Party Tools da das richtige sind warum
macht es Microsoft default mäßig immer beschissener kann es doch nicht sein
wie fit seid ihr mittlerweile in Pulsen ich arbeite nun seit heute morgen an einem Skript
was mit einer API kommunizieren soll ich nutze dafür die Methode requests get und greife
dann auf die URL zu mein Problem ist in der Uhr sind aber in der Methode wenn die Zeichen
in das klingt nach Urlein code oder das ist doch okay also also wenn du wenn du Urlein
code das sieht das sieht nach Urlein Coding aus oder dürfen sind sind Quotes überhaupt
coolersicher Bestandteil von Urls geht sowas
aber sie es sieht ein bisschen es sieht ein bisschen Urlein Coded aus wobei wenn das natürlich
gültige Bestandteile von der Url sind wäre komisch dass er sie encoded
kann eine Url geschweifte Klammern und Quotes enthalten geht ist das ist das legit was erlaubt
can contain curly braces ne ja ne da geht das nicht dann ist doch richtig so dann ist doch
richtig so das muss so sein in den curl macht es ja für dich schon
gehe ich mal stark von aus ein Curl wird das ganze wahrscheinlich schon umwandeln
probieren wir mal hier Curl keckel.de
warum genau gibt es die Domain keckel.de überhaupt
okay keckel.de okay das gibt es das gibt es nicht
ja slash so du meinst du meinst sowas hier im Endeffekt so wenn curl den Request schickt
wenn curl den Request schickt der Url encoded das schon für dich so das können wir uns
auch angucken ich bin mir nicht sicher ob man das na super muss
wir in den Domain nehmen wahrscheinlich die es gibt und wahrscheinlich Wireshark anschmeißen
oder sowas sonst sonst sehen wir das nicht habe ich ein Wireshark installiert
Wireshark ich gehe mal davon aus Wireshark Wireshark man
er ist okay Pogo Zudo Wireshark mach an jetzt hat er gar nicht mehr auf
1ks ich hoffe es ist jetzt da drinnen irgendwo kein plan man
ich habe kein bock das jetzt rauszusuchen aber ich gehe davon ich gehe davon aus dass
das Curl das schon encoded für dich alles
Wireshark kann IPs leaken ich wäre es überleben
ich meine ich könnte wir können es mal doch wir können es ausprobieren Leute ich habe
keine Idee wir machen einfach netcat auf was ist es nc netcat
Gnu netcat bitteschön oder oder oder bsd netcat okay nc was
minus L 8080 geht das so Curl localhosts 8080 nee
minus L minus P ich kann mir die ich kann mir die Dinge immer nicht merken ahja hier
so get okay ja okay der filter die Dinge anscheinend
einfach raus hätte ich auch nicht gedacht zumindest muss es zumindest muss das Curl
irgendwie ordentlich ordentlich machen den input aber das ist wie gesagt das ist das
ist okay dass die dinge encoded werden aber dann weiß ich auch nicht
nee habe ich noch nicht Serious Bugs also auch immer kein plan
aber das wird auf jeden Fall an Worldencoding liegen
ich meine wir können es wir können es im stream ausprobieren aber du wirst wahrscheinlich
die die Domain nicht leaken wollen wo du was abfragst oder
der hat doch bei bei ja der hat das der hat das einfach einfach raus geschmissen
hier die klammern an der stelle ich weiß nicht was passiert wenn man einfach nur
eine unmatched praise das will der eigentlich ich glaube karl super jetzt kriegt es kriegt es es
gibt es immer noch die pro version ich weiß eh nicht warum es unterschiedliche
windows versionen gibt ganz ehrlich keine ahnung warum microsoft außerhalb mehr geld
aber vielleicht ja es eigentlich gibt es überhaupt keinen sinn weil die
könnten einfach eine version machen und gut ist es geht ja nicht darum es ist ja nicht so als als
hätte jetzt ein heim benutzer probleme mit wenn seine windows installation sich theoretisch mit
einem ad verbinden lassen würde macht es halt schon ein wenig nicht und gut ist ja genau
in den get requests in jason rein machen das geht schon aber halt nicht aber halt nicht
eins zu eins in die url kopiert du musst das url encoden und dann an den parameter hängen
das geht wobei man jetzt möglich ist es ist sinn ob es sinnvoll ist
url encoded jason zu übergeben stelle ich mal in frage ja also okay wenn
du jason versuchst rein zu hauen das musst du auf jeden fall vorher url encode oder das
python request modul ist so schlau und macht das selbst das weiß ich nicht aber ja du kannst
in jason objekt also das müsste dann ungefähr so aussehen gibt es gibt es ein oder aber base
64 jetzt so zum vergleich soll das müsste dann ungefähr so aussehen du machst jetzt hier
netket du machst jetzt hier keine ahnung wie geht das hier blub gleich so und da müsste
jetzt quasi dein encoded das wie auch immer gab encoded jason rein und dann kommt das dann
kommt das auf der anderen seite auch an so muss ich weiß ich ob es ein gescheites
url encode tool url encode bash ob es da was fertiges gibt how to url encode
na für karl braucht man das nicht mit der kammer bei karl kammer den kram nämlich direkt dran
hängen wobei ich mir unschlüssig bin ob das bei einem get funktioniert da macht er nämlich
den post raus genau jq kam an verwenden ok jetzt wirds aber jetzt wirds aber super advanced
hier hyper hyper advanced warum habe ich jq nicht installiert was ist da los so ok
so machen wir mal irgendein jason objekt hier keckel ist eins nice jason objekt guck
da hast du auch schon wieder diese encodings das müsste dann bei dir so aussehen damit
das damit die abfrage funktioniert guck so müsste das aussehen in dem fall du musst
da ein jason url also wenn du es in einem get request machen willst ich würde ich würde
mich ja dagegen entscheiden ist in dem get request zu machen aber wenn die abli das haben
will meinetwegen so müsste das dann ungefähr aussehen du brauchst irgendein parameter wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich ja und da weißt du dann ein url encoded jason zu dann funktioniert das
auch das aber eine komische abli wenn die das so haben will
das machen wir heute überhaupt nicht du musst du musst also wir können das machen aber ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob sich das die leute heute geben wollen wenn ich ein web request in jason
mache jason web request in python mache jetzt und erstmal gucken ich weiß überhaupt nicht
aus dem kopf wie man in python ordentliche get requests macht
hast du studiert nee ehrlich gesagt gehts mir ziemlich geht ziemlich an mir vorbei
natürlich musst du das von hand entkommen wenn es die library nicht macht das ist wieder
so das ist wieder so komische python logik so nach dem motto die library unterstützt
das nicht und das ist nicht der way das zu machen deswegen macht man das nicht naja das
geht aber an der realität vorbei wenn der irgendeine abli aufrufen muss die so komisch
und die so kaputt gebaut ist dass es notwendig ist das zu machen ja dann ist es halt doof
wenn die library das nicht unterstützt das heißt man muss aber trotzdem machen weil
man will ja die daten raus bekommen also manchmal ist so sieht sie diese vorstellung wie was
optimales halt nicht praktikabel also der rest api ist schon mal merkwürdig mit ul
encoded im jason also das hat man doch recht recht selten ja weil weil bei der rest api
da siehts ja meistens so aus hier keine ahnung user slash eins so und das hier ist der parameter
und dann kriegst du ein jason objekt zurück dass du ein jason objekt in den get requests
reinschreiben muss ist eigentlich recht selten also meine nicht meine ist glaube ich explizit
für i3 gedacht aber es gibt andere status bars wo das geht naja gut poly bar glaube
kann das gut eww oder so kann das gut gibt einige muss markiert abgucken aber ich hab
mit beiden keine erfahrung so lass mal gucken haben irgendwas spannendes gibt es irgendwas
wir wir skippen wir skippen da mal kurz drüber banana pie banana der hat also der ist den
habe ich mir glaube ich auch mal anguckt er ist gar nicht übel der banana pie das blöde
bei allen rest api alternativen ist es eigentlich immer das gleiche die dinger sind durchaus
ok preisleistung technisch und von der hardware da geht es gar nicht drum der riesen vorteil
beim rest api ist die große anzahl an custom ja dinger die halt nur für die rest api header
gedacht sind wenn du einen kompatiblen header hast hast du vielleicht eine chance dass es
da funktioniert und das größte ding beim rest api und das ist auch der hauptgrund schlechthin
warum das ding nach wie vor so beliebt ist ist das ganze ökosystem drumherum also sprich
die millionen tutorials blog posts videos tools dass ein ordentliches debian drauf läuft
mit aktueller software rest api wird so für nahezu alles unterstützt treibergeschichten
und alles mögliche das ganze das ganze ökosystem drumherum ist einfach das beste für den
rest api und deswegen hält sich das auch so ja du hast zwei alternativen die sind günstiger
die haben vielleicht sogar günstiger und bessere hardware an so eine 16 g e m m c ist auch
schon was cooles ja und das ist das das ist das hauptproblem
und sie vier die autore dinger sind tatsächlich ganz nice ich hatte auch und ich habe auch
noch ein die haben aber auch das gleiche ja das ist irgend so ein zusammengefrickeltes
ubuntu glaube ich bei dir oder oder ambient oder sowas in den zusammengefrickel des os
was du im endeffekt nicht benutzen willst und sowas haben wir als nächstes liebe potato
was kann was hat der ja ist alles ungefähr ähnlich zumindest zumindest scheinen sie
rest api kompatiblen header zu haben wobei das auch oftmals täuscht manchmal sind die
ist die belegung ein bisschen anders und manchmal ganz fatal wenn es beispielsweise 5 volt anstatt
3,3 ist oder sowas an manchen pins wo es 3,3 sein sollte dann macht sie dir sogar geräte
damit kaputt wenn du pech hast das wie gesagt das ökosystem ist das hauptsächliche dass
die alternativen alle nicht wirklich ziehen an der hardware scheitert es eigentlich gar nicht
so lasst mal gucken was können wir uns dann anschauen irgendwas gibt es auch bestimmt
wem was schreit sov im silicon willi google steckt in microsoft falle dank chat gpt alle
was ein titel wieder mann ok ok lassen lassen wir uns lassen wir uns zu beten kann keine
ai video ich habe keinen bock leute ich kann die ganzen ai videos echt nicht mehr angucken
aber vielleicht vielleicht hat das ja noch irgendwie was sinnigen inhalt die meisten
die meisten ai videos sind auch so langweilig und immer der gleiche krempel dass ich fand
es nach der ersten woche schon langweilig also nicht das thema sondern die videos da
drüber system an der chat der chat ist high q der chat macht hier gerade consulting kostenlos
leute ihr solltet das abrechnen djentari du musst schicken eine rechnung das finde ich
auch hast du recht von dem gucke ich auch manchmal videos aber auf irgendwelche ai videos
habe ich keinen bock seba zu suchan 95 dankeschön für den zapp der eichlau wieder am start
drop da wieder die facts dankeschön für den zapp ok was haben wir noch so i can save
you mal wollen das habe ich noch gerade schon geguckt bloß keine meetings meetings stehen
in nahezu jedem unternehmen auf der tagesordnung doch die wenigsten meetings werden von teilnehmerinnen
und teilnehmern als nützlich oder gar hilfreich angesehen sondern viel eher als lästig und
zeitraum woran liegt das gibt es gute und schlechte meetings und wie lassen sich meetings
besser machen die besten meetings sind gar keine meetings haben man sonst noch android
versus ios 30 minuten so lang how to protect linux from hackers my security strategy okay
ssh keys verwenden und keine unnötigen ports aufmachen braucht man sonst noch irgendwas
hält mir so spontan jetzt nix ein was man unbedingt machen müsste du musst doch nicht
mal irgendwie ufw oder in the firewall oder sonst oder irgendwelche regeln reinschreiben
einfach nur die ports aufmachen die nötig sind und schon ist gut ok wir skippen wir
skippen da mal kurz drüber kaspersky insta ja ok wir skippen da mal kurz drüber
hackers ok update your software da hat er recht ja package updates machen ist sinnvoll
das würde ich jetzt aber nicht unbedingt zu so einer protection your server zählen weil
ja es zählt schon auf jeden fall dabei das ist aber was was ich jetzt überall sehen
würde nicht jetzt explizit nur auf surfer gemünzt so ja gut sowas kann man natürlich
machen sowas wie selinux und sowas sei selinux oder se linux ich weiß gar nicht wie man
das auch das kann man natürlich machen aber in der regel fährst du eigentlich schon komplett
sicher genug wenn du ssh keys verwenden selbst du musst auch nicht mehr ssh keys verwenden
es ist einfach angenehme ssh keys zu verwenden und einfach nur den port aufmachen du brauchst
und fertig auto updates bin ich jetzt nicht unbedingt ein großer fan von auto updates
sind gut in manchen bereichen ansonsten muss man sich überlegen ob man das machen will
spätestens mit kernel updates geht ja eh nicht automatisch da musst du neu starten
gibt zwar mittel und wege aber in der regel startest du neu ok update your software don't
forget your docker containers das ist auch klar secure your ssh access ja das ist das
ist richtig na gut allein schon weil der user jetzt in der dockergruppe drin ist ist er
ja so quasi schon mehr oder weniger root ssh keys zwei fakte auto identifizierung
oder ja das kann man tatsächlich machen ich bin blind fast das kann man tatsächlich
machen das ist sogar ganz sinnvoll gerade gerade mit so einer also ja kann man machen das
ist vielleicht auch ganz sinnvoll aber
es bringt also ich will jetzt nicht das falsche sagen aber natürlich bringt das was aber
auf der anderen seite ich denke nicht dass es meistens wirklich notwendig ist sein login
irgendwie per zwei fakte autentifizierung zu schützen also sein ssh login mit keys
der key hat ein password drauf das brauchst du erstmal und musst an den ssh key kommen
aber ja kann man natürlich kann man natürlich machen in größeren enterprise umgebung läuft
das ja eh anders da ist es ja meistens so dass es irgendwelche ich habe jetzt vergessen
wie der ganze kram eigentlich offiziell heißt aber dass du beispielsweise dich gar nicht
mehr so ohne weiteres einloggen kannst mit admin rechten sondern erstmal in irgendeinem
portal temporär admin rechte dir freischalten muss ich habe ich habe vergessen wie das
konzept heißt es gibt so das da gibt es so einen über über übergeordneten begriff
dafür also du kannst dich zwar einloggen auf dem system aber du kannst keine du hast keine
ruhe ne ne ne ne nicht zero trust es gibt so einen es gibt so einen extra begriff dafür
für dieses du holst dir die rechte nur dann wenn du sie brauchst ne ne ne auch nicht pimp
ich weiß nicht es gibt so ein überbegriff dafür das ist ja in größeren umgebung so
wobei das auch sehr nervig sein kann aber das ich meine ich will ich will jetzt nicht
sagen dass es unsinnig ist zwei fakte mit autentifizierung das ist schon sinnvoll
ob es so dass so der wahnsinn zu gewinnen ist mit bei zusätzlich zu ssh keys muss man
sich fragen du musst ein ssh key verlieren also wenn du dir gedanken darüber machst
über so ein angriffsszenario dass jemand deine rechner zu hause übernimmt und deine
ssh keys klaut dann ja wenn man das für ein realistisches bedrohungsszenario hält dann
ist zwei fakte autentifizierung natürlich sinnvoll man kann auch mehr machen man kann
auch port knocking machen und so spiritien aber ich persönlich bevorzuge ist simpel
in dem fall einfach ssh keys allein schon weil es viel einfacher ist als passwörter
es ist gar nicht mal unbedingt wenn das password ausreichend lang ist jetzt irgendwie extrem
viel sicherer es ist aber sicher bei default du kannst kein zu kurzes password nehmen oder
sowas und es ist auch einfacher und angenehmer mit ssh keys ja und dann kann man ufw einschalten
oder alternativ einfach wirklich nur die ports aufmachen die auch auf sein müssen
und dann ist gut damit fährst du schon mal relativ gut hast du schon mal ecd sa benutzt
ja vor zwei tagen oder so weil das mittlerweile glaube ich sogar github für neue keys empfiehlt
wenn ich jetzt war da mal github generate ssh key guck mittlerweile empfiehlt das empfiehlt
das github und ich habe es mal nach der offiziellen github best practice generiert mal den ssh
key also ist noch gar nicht so lange her ok zwei faktor alternativ don't expose unused
service genau das ist eigentlich der mit abstand wichtigste punkt nur die ports aufmachen
die man braucht wenn das ding in webserver laufen lassen soll auf port 443 dann muss
man halt auch mal gucken dass das ding auch nur an port 443 lauschen und dann muss man
nicht noch tausend andere sachen ins internet aufmachen und schon gar nicht ein proxy ins
internet hin aufmachen use the firewall wie gesagt kann man machen wenn da mehrere services
drauf laufen und man nur bestimmte exposen will aber das ist der mit abstand wichtigste
tipp nur services also nur ports aufmachen die man auch offen haben will reverse proxy
ja ist auch ist natürlich sinnvoll wenn man web services oder sowas drauf laufen hat vor
allem machen die dinge auch gleich let's encrypt für dich mit das geht immer aber bei einem
einzelnen server irgendwo bei einem cloud anbieter eher weniger ja ok ja klingt doch
alles sinnvoll wie gesagt aber meistens ist man auf der sicheren seite ist das haki und
nur ports aufmachen die man auch im internet haben will und da ist in der regel eigentlich
auch gut so was haben wir denn was was lasst doch mal irgendwas was was komm wir gucken
jetzt wir gucken uns jetzt doch an wir gucken jetzt noch ein android versus ios was ist
sicherer das video ist doch garantiert in deutsch oder warum ist der titel ach youtube
ist wieder der meinung ich muss das übersetzt bekommen ja der stimmt ja überhaupt nicht
also ich weiß er sagt es absichtlich so wie manche leute das sagen aber ich erinnere
mich nur daran dass du vor noch nicht allzu langer zeit einfach eine textnachricht schicken
musstest an ios mit manipulierten zeichen drin und ich weiß nicht ob du wirklich zugriff
aufs gerät bekommen hast oder ob du das gerät kaputt machen konntest du zum abschluss bringen
konntest das ist auch nicht allzu lange her so dinger passieren unter ios selbstverständlich
auch stimmt doch gar nicht android ist viel offener und dadurch wisst ihr an was mich
die diskussion erinnert j station versus wixbox einfach sicherer smartphones begleiten fast
jeden von euch täglich und wir speichern mittlerweile die sensibelsten daten darauf
ab für einen hacker das ist korrekt heute heute kam übrigens mal neues iphone 14 und das erste
heut komm her ich muss es mal kurz in die hand nehmen und als erstes was mir aufgefallen ist
ich habe das ich habe das in die hand gelaufen festgestellt meine güte also sind iphone 14 pro
für günstige 1250 euro für ein fucking smartphone muss ich mal vorstellen die haben echt den arsch
offen mittlerweile gut aber ich auch weil ich habe den kam ja auch noch gekauft das wollte ich
jetzt sagen das erste was mir aufgefallen ist der krempel hat ja noch weiter rausstehende kameras
als mein anderes iphone 11 oder so was hier liegt da geht es noch und die dinger die sind
richtig fett also wenn du das jetzt auf den tisch flach legst das wackelt einfach nur noch
abartig rum und kratzt im zweifelsfall auf den kameralinsen oder so ja das ist das ist richtig abartig
ich muss mir jetzt eine hülle holen die die hülle macht das iphone halt einfach viel fetter weil
die kameras so weit raus und kameras gucken bestimmt drei millimeter drüber raus also insofern man hätte
man hätte einfach das gehäuse drei millimeter dicker machen können hätte man auch fetteren
akku reingekriegt verstehe ich nicht gut weiter gucken wir uns das video machen
immerhin ist das sowas wie unser ausgelagertes gehirn fotos erinnerungen kontakte mein aus also
ich habe zwei ausgelagerte gehirne einmal meine shell history und den twitch chat nachrichten
aber auch der kalender oder euer online banking sind brutale mittel für einen hacker erpressung
absolut perfekte phishing nachrichten aber auch der zugang zu anderen geräten von eurem
smartphone aus beispielsweise euer heimnetzwerk sind so super juicy die will jeder haben deswegen
muss man heutzutage einfach sicher sein und wir klären heute diese uralte streit frage was ist
sicherer heute gehen wir diesem ewigen streit android versus ios aus einer cyber security
perspektive nach sind also da bin ich aber gespannt nutzer sicherer in den letzten jahren gab es jetzt
zum beispiel immer wieder vorfälle von viren im play store bei google die eben millionen
menschen befallen haben was wir schon mal direkt festhalten können android ist ein system das
jeder hersteller nutzen kann es gibt android handys von google ja es kann jeder hersteller
nutzen aber es kann nicht jeder hersteller updaten das problem hatte ich auch schon
frisches gerät gekauft nie updates bekommen ok mittlerweile ist es ein bisschen besser geworden
mittlerweile ist es ein bisschen besser geworden ich habe letztens in video geguckt dass samsung
mittlerweile auch ganze haltet euch fest ganze vier jahre updates gibt auf ihre 1500 euro smartphones
da muss man sagen in dem fall ist das mit ios tatsächlich angenehmer ios bekommt sogar noch
iphone iphone es hat sogar die ersten iphone ss haben glaube ich noch ios 15 bekommen also sprich
das wurde seit die sind von 2016 glaube oder so ok oder iphone se release date
2016 also das sind jetzt das ist ziemlich das ist sieben jahre alt also das kann man sich
ja nicht beschweren von schaumi und noch von zig anderen china chinesen die hersteller dinge kaputt die china chinesen von xiaomi machen
können für die android eigentlich nix kann ios hat es da einfacher da gibt es nur apple
behaltet das im kopf also direkt ein mit diesen 15 aspekten 15 alles will das aber wissen ja ok
das video ist auch nicht umsatz 30 minuten lang das erste was wir sichern wollen sind eure dateien
dazu gehören daten die apps wie zum beispiel der kalender bei euch auf dem smartphone natürlich
ablegen aber natürlich auch eure fotos oder videos im besten fall sollten die natürlich nicht
jedem mit zugriff auf euer gerät zur verfügung stehen sonst reicht ja schon ein einfacher deep aus
um euch zu hacken ich habe früher regelmäßig daten von freunden gerettet die ihre zugangsdaten
vergessen haben das hätte ich natürlich auch ohne ihre zustimmung machen können und ich weiß dass
das nicht ganz so gut angekommen wäre ein glück dass android seit android sieben schon die
datei basierte verschlüsselung unterstützt dabei werden dateien komplett verschlüsselt so dass sie
niemand mehr öffnen kann außer euch selbst wie etwa eure irgendwie die musik im hintergrund was
ist das dass sie niemand mehr das hat ein bisschen was ich ich will jetzt ich will es jetzt nicht zu
laut sagen aber die musik im hintergrund hat ein bisschen was von musik kann außer euch selbst wie
etwa eure bilder ab daten oder natürlich eure dadurch können die apps nicht zugreifen wenn
sie gerade lust haben die metadata verschlüsselung gibt seit android 9 die verschlüsselt sogar die
namen eurer verzeichnisse berechtigung und erstellungs und änderungszeiten von allen
dateien warum weil sonst jeder ausfinden kann wann ihr welche app das letzte mal verwendet habt und
auch das kann als angriff benutzt werden oder findet ihr es cool wenn jeder weiß wann ihr das
letzte mal auf tinder wart seit android 10 bin gar nicht auf standart und erzwungen vom system selbst
die dateien werden immer wenn ihr sie braucht entschlüsselt und direkt wieder verschlüsselt
genau dasselbe passiert aber auch bei apples ios und auch beide hersteller nutzen es 256
bei apple da es erinnert mich wieder an diese geschichte mit wo das fbi ich glaube es war das
fbi gesagt hat apple ist so böse die helfen uns nicht ein iphone zu entschlüsseln kann sich
da noch jemand dran erinnern und apple hat dann gesagt wir wissen es doch selber nicht genau und
da habe ich mich immer gefragt bei solchen aktionen frage ich mich immer ist das einfach nur
marketing show also sowohl für apple als auch für das fbi um besser ihren job zu machen also
marketing show für apple in form von auch guckt mal her sogar das fbi kann unsere geräte nicht
knacken und das das zweite ist dass das fbi so tut als wäre es so um die leute in sicherheit
zu wiegen da musste ja mittlerweile mit allem rechnen ja eigentlich für den sub mind games
genau steht da steht da was steht da was von military crate encryption oder so ich hab es
jetzt nicht gesehen aber das schreiben die gerne hin wobei man halt sagen muss jeder benutzt
tagtäglich military crate encryption 50 für die verschlüsselung ein algorithmus der allgemein
hin als sicher gilt und auch wenn ihr heute den stärksten super computer 1000 jahre lang
rechnen lasst kann der ganze graben nicht geknackt das ist teilweise das ist teilweise noch noch
heftiger man muss mal muss das mal hochrechnen du hast teilweise dort also die die chance das
password zu erraten brute force technisch ist manchmal geringer als vermutet wird wie
viele teilchen es überhaupt im gesamten universum gibt im gesamten sichtbaren universum oder so nach
dem motto du müsstest länger rechnen seit das universum existiert so das ist teilweise
ganz abgedreht und an der stelle kann man nur sagen bei passwörtern das wichtigste muss ich
vielleicht einfach noch mal kurz einwerfen wir gerade dabei sind das wichtigste bei passwörtern
ist die länge nicht so sehr die der zeichenvorrat der ist natürlich auch wichtig aber die länge
die länge ist wichtig unterschiede gibt es nur bei der schlüsselverwaltung bei apple verwaltet
die sogenannte secure enclave die schlüssel die eure daten verschlüsseln und dafür sorgen dass
das system eben sicher ist was übrigens immer beim start von eurem system überprüft wird dann
kann man sich darauf verlassen dass man wirklich ein echtes ios hat und nicht in der zwischenzeit
zum beispiel das smartphone sich verändert hatte und plötzlich ein virus im system ist die secure
enclave ist ein hardware chip der kryptographische schlüssel speichert und überprüft dass die
schlüssel als muss man ihn lassen coole namen haben sie ja für ihre dinger auch wirklich nicht
missbraucht werden es ist quasi unmöglich die secure enclave zu knacken selbst wenn ihr anfangen
sie aufzubrechen und auszulöten denn tut man das zerstört man zumindest nach dem design die
secure enclave und man kommt trotzdem eben dann nicht an die schlüssel die secure enclave wurde
explizit für apples software und hardware erstellt das pendant auf android ist ein dreistufiges
modell in dem der keystore läuft manche android systeme speichern alle schlüssel leider nur in
der software das heißt im umkehrschluss dass wenn jemand zugriff auf die hardware hat er
am ende auch einfach die software knacken kann das ist doof deswegen gibt es natürlich auch von
android etwas dass das ganze realisieren möchte und zwar trusty beziehungsweise die trusted
execution environment die überschlüssel in der hardware feststellt ob die software verändert
wurde noch besser ist aber das ist ein bisschen wie damals bei der ps3 hardware security module
kurz hsm das sich auf android strongbox nennt strongbox schützt sogar vor hardware angriffen
durch zum beispiel spekta oder meltdown die vor einer weile auf den prozessoren rumgewütet haben
oder eben zum beispiel wenn jemand euer handy cloud und das dann angreifen möchte sehr sehr
geil leider haben nicht alle android ein hsm achtet ihr beim kauf darauf ob euer smartphone
einen extra sicherheits chip hat und dass der auch wirklich überprüft und geprüft wurde perfekt
aber das ist bei android life seriously ich glaube niemand achtet darauf ich denke mal das wird
jetzt auch sagen die meisten wissen doch noch nicht mal dass sie vielleicht darauf achten
sollten ich hätte es bis jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch nicht gewusst ok ich habe das problem ich
habe mir lange keine android geräte mehr gekauft ich habe android geräte hier aber keine android
smartphones zum beispiel meine ganzen home automation dashboards sind android tablets
ja leider hersteller abhängig somit geht diese runde an apple ich muss hier mal ganz kurz los
werden wie faszinierend ich es finde was sowohl apple als auch android im hintergrund alles tun
wenn wir ehrlich sind sind das features und themen die auch für windows tut auch ziemlich viel im
hintergrund plus leider ziemlich viel was man nicht will desktop pc ist eigentlich relevant
wären und dort wird tatsächlich weniger wert drauf gelegt linux mac und windows erst mal
so sicher zu bekommen wie ein mobiles gerät ist gar nicht mal so einfach aber es ist möglich
ich lese persönlich recht viel zu diesem thema um immer auf dem neuesten stand zu bleiben und
magazine sind da eine möglichkeit eine runde eine runde sellout ja man muss aber auch der
der fernes halber sagen auch wenn windows vielleicht richtige abfuck ist in vielen
bereichen und gerade auch das ganze telemetrie gesammelt ich meine wenn du bin aus neu installierst
musste erst mal fünf minuten auf 999 klücken und nein bedeutet oftmals nur minimale datensenden
und nicht gar keine datensenden winners macht aber security technisch auch relativ viel
und da muss man da kann man microsoft so sehr gar nicht mehr aber das stimmt schon mobil mobile
geräte sind allein schon durch die ganzen die folgt man sich durch das ganze sandboxing und
wie apps und solche geschichten in der regel deutlich deutlich sicherer auch schon von von
haus aus was kommt denn jetzt eigentlich für den sellout und mit unserem heutigen sponsor
reedley müssen die nicht mal teuer sein klar wenn ich mir alle 6000 magazine die ich bei
reedley lesen kann kaufen würde dann wäre ich aber der erste monat für nur ich hatte mal
ein pc welt aber wirklich ein argument dazu kommt digitalisierung und alles noch klein war
papiergramm mehr ich persönlich kann euch übrigens wärmstens das linux magazine empfehlen und auch
pc welt hat spannende artikel mein persönliches highlight ist ja aber ein ziemlich deutsches
problem denn sagen wir mal man liest in der pause mal noch kurz am abend einen artikel und am
nächsten tag muss man zu einem podcast nach stuttgart fahren auf der fahrt hat man aber
natürlich kein internet warum kann man den podcast nicht einfach übers internet aufnehmen
auch daran hat reedley gedacht denn ihr könnt einfach offline weiter lesen wo ihr aufgehört
habt danke buchmark also bitt locker ich weiß das ist nicht so schlimm wie ich es jetzt darstelle
ist mir auch klar aber ich muss muss aber klar bitt locker ist bei mir unten durch seitdem am
anfang die meldung die runde gemacht hat es gibt die möglichkeiten bei einem bei einem
vergessenen password das irgendwie wieder zu restoren ich sage aber auch gleich dazu ich
habe mich damit nie im detaill beschäftigt wahrscheinlich ist es bei genera betrachtet gar
nicht so schlimm wie sie es angehört hat und das darf bei ordentlicher verschlüsselung einfach
nicht sein wenn das ding verschlüsselt ist und wenn du dein password vergessen hast dann
muss es eben weg sein beziehungsweise nicht zugreifbar sein das ist halt so weil sobald
es recover bar ist ist es auch recover bar von jemand anderem als dir direkt den link in der
beschreibung aus denn eigentlich ist zumindest android im kern ein linux oder zumindest sehr
nah dran und das zeigt sich bei der verwendeten security software die security software ist
dafür zuständig zugriffe zu verwalten wer darf eigentlich schlüssel nutzen wer darf dateien lesen
oder auf die kamera zugreifen das nennt sich zugriffskontrolle und wird bei android von
se linux geregelt ach das wusste ich gar nicht wusste gar nicht dass der android auch se linux
professionellen linux bereich wirklich bekannt ist da sie echt eine richtige sicherheitswand ist
allerdings muss man sagen se linux konfig ist teilweise ein bisschen abartig deswegen ist es
ganz ganz ist es relativ praktisch wenn man quasi das mitschneiden lässt was programme machen
möchten und sich daraus am ende regeln erstellen lässt das ist deutlich angenehmer als da irgendwas
zusammen zu wussten security enhanced linux und erlaubt zugriffskontrolle im system innersten zu
regeln und dadurch effizient datendiebstahl zu verhindern dabei kann man alles extrem gut
anpassen und ebenso verändern dass es halt genau auf android passt bei apple macht das nur nur mit
dem x was leichtes nu und konfigurieren lasst es mal nicht richard stahlmann himself hören dass
das ding nu heißt das ist eindeutig viel zu nah dran an knu allow me to interject for a moment
oder wie auch immer die chatnachricht geht könnte es doch nicht einfach zu x nu nennen
aber dafür weniger kontrolle und flexibilität bietet x nu oder nur ist allerdings keine extra
software sondern bezeichnet den kompletten betriebssystem kern von ios der regelt alle
prozesse des betriebssystems im kern tun aber sowohl se linux als auch nur dasselbe auch beim
zurücksetzen auf werkseinstellungen machen beide plattformen es sehr gleich der verschlüsselung
skis löschen euer system auf werkseinstellung zurücksetzt konnte man früher recht leicht etwas
böses damit tun daten werden auf einem chip nie vollständig gelöscht erst wenn sie mehrfach
überschrieben wurden kann man sie nicht mehr wieder herstellen das heißt einfach alles auf
werkseinstellung zurücksetzen also auch die rechte von allem und dann halt einfach den gleichen
schlüssel benutzen weil der sich nicht geändert hat um die daten wieder herzustellen und dann alle
daten entschlüsseln ja das ist doof und ein angriff deswegen sieht das eher so aus der
schlüsseln der ja all eure dateien verschlüsselt wird ganz einfach direkt mit gelöscht genau dann
können auch eure ehemaligen daten nicht das ist übrigens relativ ähnlich zu wie es sicher
erase funktioniert bei ssd ist jetzt habt ihr schon mal eine ssd secure erased oder sogar
ein advanced enhanced secure erased gibt er da zwei verschiedene zwei verschiedene sachen
das ist das ist da ähnlich ja mit den meisten ssd es geht das ist da ähnlich du musst dafür
ein quasi neues password vergeben also einen neuen key und danach nach dem reset wird es gleich
inklusive dem key gelöscht also wird quasi der controller oder nicht der controllers controllers
das falsche was quasi so das mapping auch von datenblöcken zu zu ordnung wird wird gelöscht
und dadurch dass einige ssd ist das interne schon alles verschlüsseln wenn er den verschlüsselung
key weg wirft es weg dementsprechend geht es um secure erase auch ziemlich schnell
ja das ist richtig ob das wirklich so ist dass dann alles weg ist das weiß nur der ssd hersteller
ist hier so genauso wie bei apple und bei android da kannst du dir nur vertrauen dass es richtig
funktioniert oder nicht das dumme ist halt auch du kannst dich bei der ssd ja auch mit überschreiben
nicht so wirklich drauf verlassen dass deine daten weg sind bei einer magnet festplatte ist es
einfach es gibt ja auch glaube sogar magnet festplatten die prinzipiell den secure erase
unterstützen da ist es einfach so man überschreibt einfach einmal mit nullen muss noch nicht mal
random daten sein vollkommen egal man überschreibt einfach mal mit nullen die ganze disk und gut ist
wer auf nummer sicher gehen will macht das zweimal aber das ist eigentlich bei aktuellen platten gar
nicht notwendig und ja bei ssd ist gut bei ssd könnte man dann vielleicht irgendwie so ein best
off machen keine ahnung wegs reset überschreiben noch mal wegs reset oder so aber ja keine ahnung
aber einfaches überschreiben bringt auf jeden fall nicht kannst du mal erklären warum das bei
ssd nicht funktioniert bei festplatten hast du ja noch ganz klassisch deine magnet spuren also
sprich alles das wurde über deine betriebssystem schnitt stellen zum festplatte beschreiben drauf
zugreift ist physisch so auf der platte vorhanden also wenn du quasi von null bis 100 die platte
voll schreibst dann ist einmal die platte ja du hast vielleicht ein paar reserve sektoren irgendwie
noch so aber dann ist wenn du die platte voll schreibst von null bis 100 dann ist jeder sektor
auf der platte auf null also wenn du den einmal von von anfang bis ende überschreibt dann ist jeder
sektor auf der platte auf null bei eine ssd ist das nicht so wenn du die ssd einmal überschreibst
dann sorgt der controller und das wir leveling und was es da nicht alles drinne gibt nicht
zwangsläufig dafür dass alle zellen in dieser ssd überschrieben wurden da können immer noch
rückstände sein weil du bei der ssd nicht direkt quasi auf die einzelnen flashe zellen zugreift
sondern du sagst ja nur dem controller mach mal und am strich gesehen wird es wahrscheinlich
reichen die ssd zu unter zu zu überschreiben ja wenn schon will man sehr richtig machen
praktisch wird wahrscheinlich niemand danach deine ssd ordentlich auslesen ob es möglich ist sei mal
dahingestellt also machen die on the fly quasi eine komprimierung dass das speichern und lesen
effizienter macht das könnte sein dass sie komprimieren oder so aber was jede ssd macht
ist wie leveling also sprich die zellen die die flash der flash speicher auf eine ssd der hat
ja nur bestimmten bestimmte lebensdauer so deswegen hat ja auch eine ssd mehr kapazität als draufsteht
die ist zwar nicht verfügbar aber die ist da drinne also jede ssd hat ja noch reserve dabei
eingebaut da kannst du nicht drauf zugreifen weil der controller das nicht anzeigt aber das
ist eingebaut so und was so in der ssd was so ein controller macht ist der verteilt zum
beispiel deine zugriffe deine schreibzugriffe so dass die speicherzellen gleichmäßig benutzt
werden oder wenn eine kaputt ist wird die rausgemappt unter der haube da kriegst du nix von mit
also es heißt im endeffekt wenn du jetzt was schreibst auf der ssd sagen wir mal du machst
dd dd die ersten das erste megabyte schreibst du schreibst du schreibst ein megabyte große
datei auf die ssd so und dann schreibst du an die gleiche stelle andere datei dann bedeutet das
durch dieses real leveling nicht dass die alte datei restlos von der ssd runter ist an der stelle
wo der controller die gleichen flashzellen benutzt wird sie überschrieben und dort wo
der controller jetzt sagt ach nee wir benutzen jetzt einfach andere flashzellen dafür ist sie
dann eigentlich noch da aber der controller map das halt um und nimmt andere flashzellen dafür also
kann sie meine ssd auch mal überschreiben nicht sicher sein ob wirklich alles weg ist natürlich
es ist extrem unwahrscheinlich dass irgendjemand da dran geht und deine ssd danach ausliest also
dass in der praxis muss man sich da wahrscheinlich nicht so viele gedanken drüber machen aber
secure erase ist ein standard der genau das ja eigentlich auch gar nicht mehr notwendig machen
soll indem du einfach die die keys löst und ich bin mir gar nicht 100 prozentig sicher wie
secure erase genau funktioniert glaube du löst ich glaube du löst die die ganzen zuordnungen im
controller und du änderst auch den internen den den verschlüsselung ski dann kannst du es kannst
es vergessen ja ja guck mal weiter sonst wird das heute nichts mehr wieder hergestellt werden da
der schlüssel aber auf der trusted platform war kommt dann also auch niemand mehr an diesen
schlüssel den kann man ja sowieso nicht auslesen und die daten können selbst wenn sie wieder
hergestellt werden nicht mehr entschlüsselt werden es ist also ein sicherer prozess bei
beiden herstellern ach und übrigens wenn euer gerät gestohlen wird könnt ihr einfach so über
eurem google oder apple account alle daten von eurem gerät löschen die sind 2e verschlüsselt
aber man weiß ja nie ich kenne ja meine pappenheimer mit der pin 1 2 3 4 ja die gibt
es aber hey man kann aber wie kann das schlecht sein das ist wahrscheinlich die meist benutzte
pin das ist so etabliert und best practice wie kann es schlecht sein ich benutze auch immer
123 456 als passwort so viele leute benutzen dass das kann nicht schlecht sein smartphone
an dem pc anschließen und alles umgehen oder naja nein um die verbindung mit anderen geräten
zu verwalten nutzt android die android debug bridge adb ja und das media transfer protokoll
mtb adb ist eigentlich für entwickler gedacht aber meistens musste doch eigentlich musste
nicht schon ein bisschen her wo ich mal so ein ding geroutet habe haben wir sogar im stream
gemacht by the way da musstest du erst entsperren in die developer tools gehen die developer
tools anschalten das ist auch bei android diese geschichte drücken sie neun mal die
developer tools und dann drücken sie neun mal auf info dann gehen die developer tools
da musstest du glaube ich usb debugging noch einschalten auszuführen die man eigentlich
nicht ohne weiteres ausführen sollte also quasi sicherheitsmechanismen ein bisschen
umgehen es ist also normalerweise deaktiviert dummerweise gab es einige fälle wo geräte
von dritt anbietern wie schaumy oder huawei die schiedag genau diese adb aktiviert hatten
und man so natürlich das gerät erstmal angreifen konnte man konnte dann also apps installieren
ohne dass der nutzer das wollte dennoch heutzutage selbst wenn man zugriff auf adb bekommt kann
man gar nicht so viel machen android wurde hier als offenes system designed mit viel
freiheit aber wenig was man kaputt machen kann weil man einfach keine rechte hat wenn
ich zugriff auf adb bekomme habe ich noch immer keine möglichkeit alles auszuführen
ich habe keine root rechte dazu müsste ich erst mein handy routen und das ist das faszinierende
dabei ich kann ja das wollen ja auch viele hersteller nicht über vielen geräten geht
es gar nicht mehr gescheit leider beispielsweise bei den neuen amazon fire hd10 dinger da kannst
es komplett knicken mit routen leider die fire tablets waren richtig nice solange man
custom firmware flashen konnte aktuell bleibt dir nur noch amazon die ploten übrig dass es dich
nicht mehr so sehr nervt ja das ist das ist wahrscheinlich geschichte fire hd10 tablets in
zukunft dass sie sich lohnen zwar apps über adb installieren aber die können am ende wenig
bis gar nichts kaputt machen aber dazu nachher noch ein bisschen mehr was glaubst du wie das
mit android im auto wird warum was meinste du meinst du meinst jetzt nicht android auto
beziehungsweise carplay sondern du meinst android also mein auto hat dann android drauf also mein
mein elektro fiat mein fiat 500 e der hat der läuft auf android basis dass das ganze
entertainment system das läuft auf android basis erkennt man auch an den icons und ich
war auch schon in dem menü und festgestellt wenn man im wlan wenn man im wlan menü ein
bisschen zu sehr rumklickt kommt man in kaste menus rein und sowas das will fiat wahrscheinlich
nicht dass das geht aber es funktioniert ja das ist ganz nice du merkst nicht wirklich davon dass
es android ist also dass es das ist eine oberfläche custom ist ein bisschen von fiat an den icons
erkennst du es und halt so an manchen an manchen dinger und so dass das material design von der
oberfläche und sowas erkennst du schon dann könnte ein android drunter stecken das funktioniert
wunderbar auch der zusammen auch die letztes zusammenspiel mit carplay ist ist ganz nice
ich finde das gar keine schlechte idee ehrlich gesagt dass die hersteller android nehmen anstatt
eben ihr eigenes oberflächen geraffel da zusammen zu zu frickeln also ich gehe nicht davon aus dass
mein fiat android versions updates bekommen wird der wird mit ach und krach manchmal wenn es
irgendwie relevant sein sollte security updates bekommen aber selbst das ist wahrscheinlich zum
größten teil nicht nicht wirklich relevant weil das ja das ist ja in sich geschlossen da
kommst ja sogar nicht dran ansonsten ist vielleicht ganz gut also vielleicht ist ja ganz gut dass sie
nicht so viel patchen vielleicht will ich ja mal selbst mein auto exploiten das android system
in meinem auto exploiten in ein paar jahren wenn es dort mehr funktionen mit customized
android drauf gibt oder so doch bei der inspektion wenn es updates gibt schon aber ich gehe davon aus
dass fiat da keine großen major updates wie versions android versionssprünge machen wird
man muss sich da auch gar nicht so viel gedanken darüber machen also selbst wenn es da custom
firmenanpassungen gibt und man flasht sein auto man flasht ja nicht wirklich das auto das einzige
was man flasht ist das entertainment system also man flasht nicht irgendwie den batterie controller
oder oder das lenkrad oder sowas das funktioniert ja unabhängig von dem infotainment system
ja du flasht das android darauf da drüber da drüber machst kannst du navigation machen
darüber kannst du carplay und sowas machen und darüber kannst du radio hören und sowas aber
das sind die eigentlichen basic steuerungen am auto haben wir damit nichts zu tun
gut bei tesla wird es wahrscheinlich anders aussehen ja tp ist dazu da um dateien zwischen
geräten zu übertragen speziell eben für fotos oder videos es kommt auch gelegentlich bei
kameras zum einsatz und hat einen entscheidenden vorteil metadata bleiben erhalten sprich wenn
ihr ein foto verschiebt dann habt ihr trotzdem noch das originale datum wann ihr das foto
aufgenommen habt mtp ist an sich ein sicheres protokoll aber auch hier können natürlich die
hersteller also samsung et cetera es falsch einstellen das ist beispielsweise 2013 passiert
das wird noch nie vorgekommen sein und damit den lock screen umgehen konnte das lag aber an
samsung und wurde repariert natürlich seit schon einiger zeit ist hier deswegen gar nichts mehr
vorgefallen weswegen ich es grundsätzlich immer noch als sicher einstufen würde apple nutzt
itunes wifi sync und airdrop eine direkte datei übertragung ist quasi nicht möglich was allgemein
bei mir in der vergangenheit zu missgunst geführt hat aber natürlich gab es auch hier schwachstellen
wie zum beispiel in 2021 als ein forscher über airdrop kontaktlisten auslesen konnte apple ist
sehr sehr limitierend während android das ganze genauso sicher gestaltet aber entwicklern mehr
optionen gibt das ist ein schema das sich hier durch das video ist enorm anstrengend gewesen
zu erstellen für ihn die ganzen beispiele die herausgesucht hat die ganzen einplendung an dem
video hat er bestimmt eine woche immer dran wiederum gebastelt bis das fertig war also das
ist wirklich anstrengend so was zu erstellen für den content creator ist das erst mal ein
unentschieden in dieser kategorie wo wir den unterschied allerdings spüren ist bei den
app kontexten android ist im endeffekt unix basiert wenn wir auf android eine app starten macht es
moment allow me to interject for a moment bitteschön genug plus linux man muss ja schon
korrekt sein an der stelle ist hier was enorm schlaues jede app gehört einem anderen benutzer
intern das heißt starten wir die kamera app gehört die zum beispiel einem neu generierten benutzer
u0 105 acht eben starten wir den kalender gehört der wiederum den benutzer u0 a81 das ist großartig
und super schlau weil durch se linux habe ich jetzt die möglichkeit jedem nutzer andere rechte
zu geben was wir im android system kann eben genauso wiederfinden jetzt weiß ich auch woher
diese ids kommen das sind die unterschiedlichen user das wusste ich gar nicht der kamerannutzer
darf auf exakt gar keine dateien vom kalendernutzer zugreifen und andersrum genauso das geniale hier
bei wenn ihr einen virus installiert habt kann der auf android nichts ansehen wenn es eine normale
app ist er hat keinen zugriff auf die banking app keinen zugriff auf kontakte das liegt einfach
am system design um jetzt die apps miteinander kommunizieren zu lassen weil das brauchen wir
halt einfach gibt's deswegen bei android den binder service der läuft im system kern und der
wiederum darf die kommunikation verarbeiten der binder ist viel genauer und flexibler als die
einzelnen berechtigung und wenn ihr sagt diese app darf auf meine bilder zugreifen dann darf die
das trotzdem nur über dem binder da gibt es ein paar unix eigenheiten warum das nötig ist aber
trust me der binder ist tausendmal geiler dadurch können die beider ist geiler sich einloggen ohne
dass die auf eure daten zugreifen können zum beispiel euren kinder wichtig aber das gilt nur
für die apps die keine administrator berechtigung haben dazu nachher noch mal mehr apple hat nur
einen einzigen benutzer und braucht deswegen ein viel komplexeres system ihre eigene sandbox hier
wird tatsächlich auch für jede app eine eigene geschützte umgebung erstellt die daten ihr code
werden darin gespeichert und nichts hat darauf zugriff und die umgebung selbst hat wiederum nur
zugriff auf sich selbst und kann dann wiederum mit dem betriebssystem interagieren genau dokumentiert
ist das allerdings naja nicht wirklich da ist der apple nur wirklich nicht berühmt dafür dass es
sonderlich gute dokumentation hätten das ist hier der definitiv schlauer im endeffekt nutzt
android ob es besser ist keine ahnung um eine sandbox zu bauen kann dadurch aber viel fein
granularer die rechte vergeben schafft man es bei ios aus der sandbox auszubrechen hat man gleich
sehr sehr viel zugriff sehr viel mehr als man haben sollte während der zugriff bei android immer noch
sehr minimal bleibt allein dadurch ist es android gleichzeitig möglich offen unsicher zu sein der
punkt geht also hier an android diesen offenen gedanken haben sich aber natürlich auch zick
hersteller zu nutze gemacht sowohl samsung als auch schaumi als auch motorola und zick andere
hersteller dürfen googles betriebssystem benutzen um ihre handy hardware zu verkaufen natürlich
dafür dürfen sie dann aber auch was machen was problematisches apps im vorfeld installieren
auch manche hersteller verdienen das ist teilweise richtig ätzend ich kann mich noch dran erinnern
ich hatte mal eine lenovo tablet was danach übrigens auch nie geupdatet wurden android lenovo
tablet da war irgendwie sieben oder acht komische lenovo apps drauf da war irgendwie komische
custom sound app drauf custom gaming center drauf so was richtiger müll ist das gewesen aber ich
will mich mal nicht beschweren das lenovo tablet habe ich nicht gekauft das lenovo update habe
ich tablet das lenovo update alter ich kann immer reden man das lenovo tablet habe ich damals auf
dem messestand der gamescom von g2a als so in so einer giveaway back gekriegt da wollte ich mich
immer drüber beschweren ich meine wenn man schon kostenlos in tablet kriegt dann will ich mal
nicht so sein wenn da blote zeug drauf installiert ist aber eigentlich cool dass man ein tablet als
giveaway kriegt oder ich bezahlte sponsorings mit apps fast mehr als durch den verkauf ihrer
hardware denn auf einem günstigen gerät können bis zu unfassbaren 400 apps irgendwo vor installiert
sein die sind aber nicht unbedingt sicher ihr müsst bedenken jede app kann grundsätzlich eine
schwachstelle haben und kann deswegen angegriffen werden mit dem sicherheitsmodell von android ist
das zwar kein weltuntergang aber es wird dann zu einem richtig fetten problem wenn der hersteller
den apps mehr rechte als vorgesehen ist das stimmt auch das ist das klingt logisch eigentlich tun
sogar die meisten hersteller genau so was das heißt wir haben apps auf dem smartphone die
beispielsweise von werk aus rechte haben alle kontakte alle daten etc zu lesen und natürlich
auch zu schrei logisch weil die hersteller muss das ja machen die der hersteller hat
schlicht und ergreifend keinen bock der spart sich entwicklungszeit und war seriously die
meisten hersteller apps sind zum größten teil komplett also ab abgrund die verschrott ja und
die dadurch leider auch schon automatisch also von diesen feuerlichen dingern sind sie nun auch
noch unsicher kann ein hacker darüber das ist ein bisschen wie früher auf dem desktop immer
norden internet security suite vor installiert war und so ein müll ausnutzen und beispielsweise
eure daten stehlen oder kontakte abgreifen das hat zwar nichts mit android an sich zu tun zeigt
aber wie zerkluftet diese ganze sache ist es zeigt die hersteller probleme die natürlich das offene
system von android ein kleines bisschen ausnutzen bei apple passiert das nicht da alle apps einfach
von haus aus von apple kommen klar die können auch schwach haben aber apple verkauft auch bei
den günstigsten modellen kein slot an den facebook messenger den man nicht mal überhaupt irgendwie
installieren kann looking at you samsung der punkt geht also ganz klar an ios aber wo wir
gerade von apps sprechen eines der wichtigsten elemente jeden gerät ist eigentlich der store
der store erlaubt mir das installiert außer der microsoft store der ist unwichtig ein neuer den
will auch keiner haben und microsoft versucht regelmäßig den irgendwie unter die leute zu
bringen aber jeder unter windows ignoriert den microsoft store und dann kommt microsoft wieder
und sagt ja ja installiert das neue zeug doch über den store und alle leute so alter geht mir
weg microsoft mit eurem kack store und dann dauert es mit ein halbes jahr da kommt microsoft wieder
mit ihrem komischen store um die ecke also ja der app store ist auf allen geräten wichtig außer
unter windows da sollte er hoffentlich mal einfach einfach verschwinden apps und ohne oder oder
gescheiten store wäre das smartphone eigentlich ziemlich useless bei android gibt es von haus aus
den play store aber es gibt auch andere stores f droid beispielsweise was hast du für ein handy
ich habe hier ich heute ist mal neues gekommen in iphone 14 die neben dran habe ich gerade noch
ein iphone 11 liegen wie gesagt warum ich mir neu gekauft habe ist nicht weil ich zu viel geld
habe und einfach geld ausgeben will sondern das iphone 11 muss ich bald abgeben in dem nur
open source apps reingenommen werden android erlaubt diese installation weil sie halt dem
user erlauben wollen sich selbst zu verletzen wenn er bock drauf hat f droid ist ein guter
store aber google erlaubt grundsätzlich auch app installation von nicht verifizierten quellen
was für entwickler übrigens ein wahrer segen ja das stimmt im vergleich also das ist auf android
viel viel angenehmer wenn du was seit launen willst selbst auf dein eigenes handy und sowas
wird es bei apple glaube ich nach sieben tagen oder so gelöscht du musst dann solche komischen
spirenzchen machen wie ein lokaler store wurde das dann immer wieder update ist draus ganz ganz
gritzfühl arsch also das ist unter android viel ist extrem viel angenehmer natürlich birgt das
auch ein bisschen angriffsfläche ja weil die leute dann auf die idee kommen auf trittanbieter
webseiten zu gehen oder auf trittanbieter stores zu gehen und sich von dort beispielsweise ansonsten
kostenpflichtige apps runterladen und ob du dann da wirklich das original bekommst oder irgendwelchen
china chinesen crap das ist immer ein bisschen fragwürdig aber es gibt ja glücklicherweise
das finde ich ganz nice es gibt ja sogar alternative stores also kannst du was wie den aurora store
nehmen zum beispiel die benutzen quasi den google store aber anonymisiert das heißt du brauchst
kein google store und du kannst trotzdem auf die inhalt des google stores zugreifen das ist
eigentlich ganz cool hat aber auch manchmal probleme mit speziell gepackaged apps und und
sonstigen sachen ansonsten f dort ist auch nice ja das ist halt wieder das was ich auch oft sage
android hat halt einen riesen vorteil wenn man auch am system was machen will es heißt es heißt
automatisierung mit tasker und solche sachen so es klingelt es soll automatisch eine kamera von
der von der haustür aufgehen und so was ohne dass es eine offizielle hersteller app von gibt das
geht halt das geht halt und der android deutlich angenehmer unter ios geht vieles schlicht und
ergreifend gar nicht und da gibt es auch keine möglichkeiten was zu machen in der richtung hat
deine firma keinen eigenen apple app store auf dem iphone ich glaube schon doch doch ich glaube
schon den habe ich nie verwendet es könnte sein dass dort irgendwie so eins zwei apps
vor installiert sind so irgendwie meine tolle rentenplane app und so was wenigstens aber eben
auch schon oft dazu geführt hat dass bezahl apps heruntergeladen werden genau genau nur und dann
am ende viren auf dem system lustig dass er genau das gleiche sagt ich habe das video nicht zu nicht
geguckt vorher das zählt aber eher zur user dummheit würde ich behaupten im eigentlichen store
sollten nur bitte keine mehr zu finden sein was aber durchaus vorkommt ja nein ja unerwartet aber
wie gesagt so viel passiert da meist nicht zumindest von haus aus die müssen euch bei
der neuesten version von android auf jeden fall nach rechten fragen und die solltet ihr natürlich
nur vergeben wenn wirklich nötig eine taschenrechner er braucht keine rechte für internet oder push
benachrichtigung und wenn dann halb mal eine werbe push benachrichtigung gekommen ist wisst ihr was
zu tun ist aber ist das bei apple wirklich besser apple quält seine entwickler ein bisschen erst
mal braucht man zig formalien bevor man überhaupt eine app veröffentlichen kann und dann wird
alles geprüft das ist abartig unfassbar nervig denn es gibt nur den app store bei apple und die
sind da wohl auch äußerst äußerst pingelig habe ich schon gehört das läuft dann sogar so weit dass
du teilweise gar nicht weißt warum sachen abgelehnt werden und manchmal wird irgendwas
abgelehnt was vorher ok war und apple sagt ihr dann halt von oben herab auch nö die app die
nehmen wir jetzt nicht mehr ist hat alles seine vornachteile beigert sich das monopol aufzugeben
obwohl das ständig gefordert wird wirklich etwas bringen tut es nicht denn auch im app store lauern
trojan es ist nur mehr auf wann sie da eben es gab schon es gab schon apps diesen app store geschafft
haben die dann aus dem internet dinger nachgeladen haben und sowas so zum beispiel guckt mal hier eine
super hilfreiche kostenlose taschenrechner ab nur dass apple übersehen hat dass sie die
taschenrechner ab zufälligerweise aus dem internet noch irgendwelche sachen nachlegt also gab es
alles schon haben auch schon heute hingekriegt dass in app store einzuschleusen tendenziell würde
ich aber das ist jetzt eine reine gefühlsache ich kann es nicht belegen ich weiß nicht denn
es ist so mein bauchgefühl sagt mir dass aber der anteil solcher solcher dreck apps im google
play store höher ist als im app store unter unter ios
an sich würde ich den punkt also eigentlich gerne lieber android geben da sie mehr stores
erlauben aber da das kein security argument ist ist das hier erst mal unentschieden aber
übrigens warum gibt es eigentlich so viel weniger malware bei apple im store warum sind android
nutzer häufiger das ziel von angriffen gut android ist verbreitet das stimmt schon aber ich bin mir
nicht sicher was die letzten zahlen waren ich glaube 25 prozent ios und der rest android irgendwie
sowas so in der größten ordnung habe ich im hinterkopf werden wir jetzt gleich sehen ob das
stimmt einfach an der beliebtheit des systems apple hat etwa ein viertel marktanteil während
ja habe ich doch habe ich doch habe ich doch ganz gut im hinterkopf gehabt oder das heißt im zweifel
dreimal so viele menschen die man mit denselben mitteln angreifen kann im fall von cyber security
ist beliebtheit leider nicht unbedingt was positives deswegen geht der punkt an apple diese ganzen
drojaner apps sind aber zum großteil wie gesagt ungefähr sie nerven indem sie euch werbung als
puschnachrichten schicken stehlen daten wenn ihr ihnen die rechte dazu gibt das tun aber die
meisten apps wenn ihr sie lasst oder glaubt ihr dass tiktok aus vorsorge all diese rechte braucht
na klar was denn sonst die möglichkeiten so eine app sind dann noch immer ziemlich limitiert wenn
ihr keine supersensiblen dinge auf eurem smartphone habt oder einfach schlau die rechte verteilt
kritisch wird es erst dann wenn es eine schwachstelle im system also bei ios oder android gibt und die
apps aus ihrer sandbox ausbrechen können und das kommt vor da kann man niemanden einen vorwurf
machen wichtig ist aber wie damit umgegangen wird sehr wichtig sogar der erste punkt sind updates
und patches das betriebssystem ja da hat er schon bisschen die arschkarte oftmals natürlich
repariert von seiten von google oder eben apple leider sehen aber viele android vertreiber es
nicht ein diese patches dann auch an euch weiterzugeben so haben eben viele android smartphones nur eine
lebensdauer von zwei jahren weil sie nur eben zwei jahre gepatcht werden apple hingegen patcht sogar
teilweise geräte die über acht jahre alt sind klar ich kann mir auch alle zwei jahre ein neues
gerät kaufen aber das hier ist der punkt der mich immer wieder fast dazu bringt meine freunde und
familie aus dem wifi zu werfen es ist völlig normal mit einem android ohne security updates
rumzulaufen was definitiv nicht normal sein dürfte bei apple passiert das wirklich wirklich lange
gar nicht allerdings gibt es bei android änderung meins zum beispiel bekommt fünf jahre eine gute
eine gute sache hat das ja immerhin ja also eine sache hat ja er hat ja android bzw google schon
gemacht ich glaube seit android 4 3 oder so ist das ja so dass der web view mittlerweile updatebar
ist über den app store also dass kein chrome mehr im system embedded ist der nicht geupdatet wird
also der geht ja mittlerweile über den app store das heißt selbst bei android geräten wo du keine
updates mehr kriegst bekommst du zumindest für so essentielle sachen wie den web view für den
system web view noch updates über den app store das ist aber auch schon ewig so wie das flakschiff
von samsung das ist ein schritt in die richtige richtung der punkt geht dennoch mit abstand an
apple und ich möchte noch mal betonen wie wichtig der ist ich habe sogar schon quasi ein eigenes
video zu diesem thema gemacht dieser punkt das geschlossenen oder fahri safari ist immer abartig
egal wo safari ist das schlimmste browser die sind so weit hinten dran was aktuelle web
technologien geht und unterstützt beispielsweise auch die pwa unterstützung alles was was da alles
nicht geht und so was also safari ist ohne scheiß der neue internet explorer zieht sich aber noch
weiter durch android ist im kern open source die google dienste sind natürlich close source das
heißt niemand darf den kabel lesen also der programm code aber beispielsweise den genannten
binder oder all die mechanismen die kann ich mir alle ansehen und überprüfen das browser benutzt
man auf ios du kannst unter ios nur safari benutzen es gibt ja keine andere möglichkeit
unter ios was anderes als safari zu benutzen du kannst jetzt zwar chrome und firefox unter
unter ios installieren oder brave oder was auch immer aber das ist alles safari
oder brave ist auch safari unter ios ja die haben ein paar sachen wie ad blocks und so was drin aber
es ist weiterhin safari sachen die safari nicht unterstützt unterstützt brave auch nicht ja das
ist alles safari das ist sogar policy von apple du darfst gar nichts anderes machen also wenn
jetzt jemand eine app bastelt mit custom browser engine dann wird die schlicht und ergreiflich
zugelassen das ist unter android übrigens auch anders habe ich auch mein video zugemacht von
nicht allzu langer zeit ja das habe ich gelesen die sind gerade dabei dass soll wohl geändert
werden doch doch das soll jetzt demnächst geändert werden aber aktuell ist das noch so
als forschern auf der ganzen welt aber natürlich auch bösartigen angreifern einfacher eine lücke
zu finden der offene quake hat schon in wahnsinnig vielen fällen dazu geführt dass google bei
android und übrigens auch bei chrome hinweise von forschern bekam und die lücken stopfen konnte
der quake von ios ist zum großteil unbekannt apple möchte niemand dritten wirklich über den
code schauen lassen das hat häufig etwas von security by obscurity und das ist immer in der
schritte eine red flag weiß niemand das in meinem code eine schwachstelle ist wird sie auch niemand
finden das stimmt eben leider so nicht aber es ist insgesamt natürlich schwerer sie zu finden
die kriminellen haben leider aber immer noch ein großes interesse daran man kann durch die
close source insgesamt also davon ausgehen dass mehr lücken noch in apple's code zu finden sind
weil einfach weniger leute drüber geschaut haben leichter zu finden sind die lücken da gibt es ja
große streitereien schon seit jahrzehnten drüber ob jetzt unter dem strich open source oder
close source sicherer ist bei android aber bei denen werden die dann natürlich direkt gemeldet
und repariert der punkt geht also wieder android wusste dir dass ein hacker der es schafft ein
apple gerät zu hacken bis zu eine million dollar bekommen kann für android können das sogar 1,5
millionen dollar sein das ist ein sogenanntes da greift tim apple höchst persönlich tief in die
tasche um das zu bezahlen aber auch wie mit sicherheitsforschern selbst umgegangen wird ist
extrem wichtig das sind die leute auf die man sich verlassen muss stellt euch so vor entweder ihr
beschäftigt zigtausend securityforscher die unfassbar teuer sind oder aber ihr bietet ein
bug bounty programm so dass die einfach alles was sie finden euch melden können und ihr könnt
dann reparieren beide firmen also apple und google haben so ein bug bounty programm übrigens meine
academy auch wollte ich nur kurz erwähnen apple hat aber in der vergangenheit securityforscher
und die gesamte community ziemlich angepisst ihr müsst euch das so vorstellen da arbeitet
jemand der einfach apple kann gut leute anpissen wobei man sagen muss ehrlich gesagt google auch
monate für umme für euch eine schwachstelle sucht und ihr antwortet dem einfach ein halbes
jahr gar nicht dann schreibt er euch noch mal ihr ignoriert ihn weiter weg und als er dann seine
schwachstelle dann wird er öffentlich dann wird er verklagt von euch und seine arbeit damit quasi
umsonst war nehmt ihr kontakt auf das macht man einfach nicht der ruf von apple ist insgesamt in
der cyber security branche weil sicherheitsvorstand kein besonders guter was das angeht weswegen
eben viele lieber bei android nach sicherheitslücken schauen es gab auch bei google immer wieder kritik
dass sie lange nicht antworten würden oder der zustand von dem report nicht ganz klar war aber
insgesamt ist es doch deutlich besser deswegen geht der punkt an android apple bezahlt aber in
seinem bug bounty programm am allerallermeisten mit abstand für seinen lock down mode das ist
ein ganz spezieller modus für eine hochgradig vulnerablen zielgruppe hier wird die security
einfach auf maximum gedreht dass manche funktionen schon gar nicht mehr funktionieren sogar
nachrichten beispielsweise hier werden die meisten anhänge blockiert face time ebenso außer ihr habt
davor keine kann die euch nicht anrufen verbindung zum pc komplett blockiert profile apple services
und sogar der browser funktioniert ok wenn apple services blockiert sind wäre das für mich
tatsächlich fast schon ein anreiz dazu reinzuschalten dadurch nimmt man einem
potenziellen angreifer alles was er irgendwie als angriffsvektor benutzen könnte dieser modus
ist unfassbar stark und für genau die zu empfehlen die wirklich anonym und sicher sein müssen also da
wo es lebensgefährlich wird wenn sie es nicht sind die zum beispiel die quellen beschützen
müssen aber ein normaler betrieb würde ich damit nicht unbedingt empfehlen android bietet
nichts vergleichbares an der punkt geht also an apple aber all die sicherheitsmaßnahmen bringen
mir wenig wenn man mein handy einfach so entsperren kann und dann doch zugriff auf alles hat deswegen
ist die authentifikation so wichtig heutzutage vor allem biometrisch das heißt vor allem mit
fingerabdruck oder gesicht alternativ die metoden von früher mit muster und pin wir müssen nicht
darüber reden dass beim muster eure fettdoben irgendwie super zeigen was genau euer muster
war das tolle bei der pin ist dass sie euch auch nach ein paar fehlversuchen aussperren also
eigentlich eine ganz gute methode das heißt es ist einfach nicht möglich jede kombination auszuprobieren
von den 10.000 möglichen kombinationen die meisten von uns nutzen aber fingerabdrücke oder face id
fingerabdrücke können angreifbar in dem man einfach ich ich ich verwende auch face id muss
ich mein face liegen gegenüber apple fingerabdruck auf das handy packt das ist zwar eher so
geheimdienst shit aber nicht ganz unmöglich hier passiert ob ihr es glaubt oder nicht sogar noch
einiges an forschung mir gefällt hier übrigens der ausdruck im poster acceptance rate richtig
gut es wird also für eure bequemlichkeit dass der scanner nicht ständig noch mal neu fragt
akzeptiert dass ihr eventuell einen gefakten fingerabdruck habt das wird aber so niedrig
wie möglich natürlich gehalten face id hatte ja vor allem am anfang richtig viele videos
produziert wo leute einfach mit einem bild das gerät entsperren konnten das ist aber besser
geworden und noch immer passiert hier viel forschung zum beispiel über tiefen weil mein gesicht nicht
einfach nur bild ist über die biometrischen signale also quasi wo meine knochen wie hängen
und so weiter und so fort idioten sicher sind aber beide systeme nicht aber da sowohl fingerabdruck
als auch gesicht bei beiden systemen vorhanden sind und bei beiden dieselben probleme gibt gibt
sie auch wieder ein unentschieden was auch immer wieder diskutiert wird ist die frage der
privatsphäre und das hier mit in diesem video unterzubringen wird einfach diesem komplexen
thema nicht gerecht deswegen hier ein kurzer vorgeschmack apple hat es ab anbietern unfassbar
schwer gemacht jemanden zu tracken im vergleich zumindest zu allerdings tracken sowohl apple
auch ihren nutzer selbst der vorteil das sind ja nicht das sind ja alles keine menschenfreunde
und sagen wir machen das nur für die für unsere für unsere user die selbst tracken natürlich
selbstverständlich weiterhin weil sie sind ja die guten und die guten dürfen natürlich tracken
android ist android selbst track seine benutzer nicht das machen die google dienste und die kann
ich im zweifel loswerden wie ihr vielleicht wisst das geht bei apple bekanntlich nicht
und beispielsweise gab es immer wieder berichte dass apple sogar vpn für seine eigenen dienste
ausschaltet um das tracking eben zu verbessern ich würde hier also mal ein unentschieden stehen
lassen auch wenn es sehr sehr unterschiedliche punkte für beide parteien gibt und man das
deutlich mehr aufdröseln müsste hast du gelesen von den deutschen isp die jetzt zusammen tracken
wollen wir einen roten faden der das ganze system definiert android ist offen und man kann was ich
was ich nach dem video besser finde ich wäre viel zu faul mich an anderes system zu gewöhnen das
kommt dabei aber ich würde auch nach dem video bei ios bleiben damit machen das kann gut sein weil
mehr sicherheitsforschung betrieben werden kann das kann aber schlecht sein wenn beispielsweise
externe händler ihre eigenen anfälligen apps installieren und den mehr rechte geben als sie
haben sollten deswegen hier mal meine zusammenfassung kauft ihr euch das schlechteste android mit
angreifbar vor installierten apps und einen eigenen kaputten store und beispielsweise nur
zwei an updates dann gewinnt natürlich apple mit zwei punkten ohne probleme diesen vergleich
achten wir allerdings darauf dass euer android ein hardware security modul hat das keine bloat
wer auf eurem gerät ist also am besten stock android verwendet wird und möglichst lange
updates geliefert werden dann kann android mit apple problemlos mithalten oder es sogar
übertreffen hier kommt es allerdings darauf an wie ihr das ganze gewichtet wem der lockdown
modus nichts bringt und wer sein handy das fünf jahre updates bekommt auch nur wirklich fünf
jahren nutzt der ist mit android besser beraten eines kann man aber definitiv sagen beide systeme
sind vermutlich besser geschützt als euer desktop rechner einfach so ein hacker auf dem smartphone
zu haben das passiert heutzutage eigentlich nur in den seltensten ausnahmefällen wenn dann ist
es vielleicht eine nervige app die euch werbung schickt viel wichtiger ist allerdings dass
euer eigenes verhalten nicht fahrlässig ist daten die ihr angebt wie so immer brain ist das
wichtigste damit hat er chat ja keine probleme also der eq hier geht er eh schon durch die
decke berechtigung die ihr verteilt phishing nachrichten auf die ihr klickt und apps die
ihr installiert messer fife eine gefahr deswegen teilt gerne das video und schaut bei meiner
academy vorbei und ich fand das video wirklich gut also der hat sich unglaublich mühe gegeben
mit den einblendungen das alles zu zeigen zu belegen unser das war bestimmt unglaublich
aufwendig das zu erstellen aber war da bestimmt ich meine ich will es nicht sagen eine woche
durchgängig aber immer mal wieder dran gearbeitet also das ist nicht nicht einfach mal fünf minuten
der stadt entstanden schaut bei rietli vorbei denn auch viele der artikel kam noch mal am ende wenn er das überhaupt selbst schneidet wahrscheinlich schneidet er das ganze nicht mal selbst aber trotzdem dann hat halt der katter aufwand gehabt aber er musste immerhin noch das source material raussuchen weil das der katter wahrscheinlich nicht selbst machen konnte
nicht schlecht sozusagen
heute ich gehe jetzt ins bett
ich muss morgen früh aufstehen
ne ist er nicht
naja machen wir den nächsten stream die nächste runde unix-porn aus dem discord es ist auch viel zu wenig es ist auch viel zu wenig als dass ich das jeden stream zeigen könnte soviel kommt ja da auch nicht rein
können wir uns vier fünf sachen angucken aber nicht pro stream
ok leute wir sehen uns machts gut
bestens zu